e
good morning welcome to
Edna I'm opening the hearing on Senate
Bill 481 and I
callose Jenny Horan who is
with Senator Perkins
P thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jenny Horan I am the Senate um minority
policy director Senator Perkins Koka
apologize that she couldn't be here with
you all today she is actually directly
across the hall introducing another one
of her prime bills and I'm sure you can
all relate to how busy today in this
session has been so please excuse her
absence um if it's all right with the
chairwoman and the members of the
committee the senator did provide me
some test testimony that I would like to
read into the
record good morning Madam CH it's in the
excuse me it's in the record for for uh
speaking to us just give us the
highlights please okay so Senator perins
quoka you know June 19th is referred to
as juneth it has a deep andrich history
in our nation it's the Day celebrated
annually by a vast number of people to
commemorate the official end of slavery
in the United States in 2019 New
Hampshire took a step forward in
acknowledging juneth as a day of
observance this bill will change that
into making it a state holiday um to
let's see the state has already a
long-standing president and there seems
little rationale for not formally
recognizing this day through
legislation um in the Years following
our state's lead many others have
followed suit by enshrining the holiday
in their own constitutions and most
notably it was recently elevated to the
federal level being established
officially as a Federal holiday in 2021
sill 481 acknowledges the his of our
country's past and it's time for juneth
to be recognized with the same legal
stat as Martin Luther King Day Martin
Luther King Jr Day Washington's birthday
Labor day and many other holidays so
Senator Perkins quoka is grateful
representative pelli did reach out to
her to provide um amendment that I
believe the representative is bringing
forward um Senator perin Koka certainly
appreciates that and understands the
attent of the representative which I'm
sure she'll speak to that herself um she
supports the Senate's position this came
out of the committee and the Senate with
full bipartisan support and not to get
in too much to I don't want to take away
from the representative introduction of
the her Amendment but the senator does
believe that um local control is very
important and and that would be her Pion
would be to remain with the Senate
position on the bill so I'm happy to
take any questions down back to the
senator and I think that concludes my
testimony thank you are there any
questions
uh do you expect this to result in a
cost to local municipalities if it
becomes a
holiday so I know that the question in
committee came up often it was something
that the committee discussed at Great
length whether or not this would affect
the union and whether or not taking the
holidays off for that um our
understanding is that there are two
separate sections in the statutes one on
the collective bargaining agreement and
one on this issue um so we are our
understanding is that it would not
impact collective bargaining agreement
in terms of local we have not heard from
anyone that says that this would impact
a cost that I'm aware of but I'm
certainly happy to check back in with
the senator and report back to the
committee if she has heard any
information to that extent thank you
other
questions okay thank you very much thank
you
representative pareli you have a card
for us
yes good morning everyone I am
representative Susan pelli Rockingham
District 19 I represent Hampton Falls
and
Kensington I offer this amendment today
to S SP 481
to honor our holidays holidays reflect
our history why do we commemorate or
celebrate holidays these special days
are designed to remember our shared
experiences these days have a
significant place in history and schools
and municipalities may be closed to
reflect this
importance this amendment simply states
that schools and municipalities use the
official name for our state holidays un
official Communications like calendars
for example so that we can continue this
shared
experience for example we don't want
juneth to be Rena renamed black lives
matter Day by certain towns or
schools so let's remember to honor our
holidays by unifying and sharing this
holiday tradition respecting our holiday
names this amendment has bipartisan
support and Representative Steve
shirtliff that wanted to be here today
but unfortunately had another um
appointment fully appointment fully
supports this
amendment so I would like to ask that
you pass the amendment to this bill to
honor our holidays and our holiday names
thank
you thank you representative dlan
thank you madam chair and representer
thank you for taking my question uh do
you know is is this is it the sponsors
intent and your intent that uh this day
would be uh the closing of all public
schools for that day or is that not
addressed oh uh this amendment just
really says whatever the holiday
designation is on our official statute
that's what schools and municipalities
and um need to use on their official
communication so it's a little
tangential to the June 13th Bill thank
you I have a question representative
parelli would this require a towns to
refer to the second Monday in October as
Columbus Day that's our official name um
in the statute so yes it would the same
thing that Christmas day is in the
statute so we would refer to Christmas
day as Christmas
day thank
you any other
questions thank you excuse me
representative Smith do you have a
question I I don't know if it's a
question or a statement Madam chair but
um schools start to close about June
13th and you give them a day off at a
time when there's exams going on it's a
bad time of the year
um I guess I'm not for the holiday uh to
interfere with another with the school
year and there I think representative
Smith that's a valid point but unless
there's a question that's probably
something for our executive session okay
thank you is there a
question
okay seeing none thank you very much all
Representative Patrick thank you madam
chair I follow up on representative
Dolan uh I have the same
question but you when you answered it
you talked about the amendment correct
let's talk about the main I'm sorry I'm
not here to just I we I could but I'm
primarily representing the amendment oh
okay thank you madam chair anyone else
gold so I want to make sure I'm
understanding the amendment um fully
does this amendment in any way um
promote the closing of schools on June
19th or any other day no the amendment
simply adds another section to the bill
to say call the use the official title
of our holidays in statute on official
Communications like calendars okay thank
you okay anyone else represent Brown uh
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my questions
so is it accurate to say that that is
happening around the nation and maybe in
New Hampshire that uh different
institutions are renaming holidays to
benefit maybe their own
agenda that was the reason for the
amendment to just remind our schools and
municipalities that this is part of our
shared experience and if everyone names
holiday is something different that
really diminishes the whole purpose of
having a holiday right thank you thank
you other
questions all right thank you very much
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on Senate Bill
481 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing all right and we will go into
executive
session does someone have have any
motion
Madame chair I'll move itl on Senate
Bill 481 I'll
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion
sure I think that um when this committee
made juneth something that would be
celebrated in New Hampshire it was it
was a big step um in the normal practice
of
this committee not supporting the naming
days and I don't
um I don't support the amendment first
of all that was presented but I
certainly and the bill itself is not
something that I'm willing to if if for
example someone wants to close on juneth
that's their
prerogative if somebody wants to
um uh not open their shop on that day
that's their prerogative but I don't
believe that we should make it a
mandatory holiday for the State of New
Hampshire until
um it comes a time when that's something
that um
is uh supported on a larger extent that
makes sense to
everyone representative I'd like after
uh i' I'd like to agree with everything
representative broa said and also
mention that the history of juneth is
much more intense in other places than
New Hampshire it didn't have a lot a lot
of effect on on our state at the time
but it
uh representative gold thank you madam
chair uh I'm I really appreciate
represent pres ative Gro his remarks too
that um that this committee worked very
hard to make it a uh a thing that New
Hampshire celebrates and with all due
respect Madam chair I I read a lot I
read a lot of New Hampshire history I've
spend I'm very absorbed in it and I
think there was more freedom happening
in New Hampshire than the general than
is generally perceived however I'm very
respectful of this committee's position
and consistent record on um on not
continuing to proliferate mandated
holidays and and again going back to
both Madam chair and uh representative
grod's comments that anybody's free to
choose a holiday if they want and and as
I understand it even at like the school
level or state level there's some um
kind of floating holidays that school
that PE that
and and that certainly happens from time
to time I've been aware of when I was on
the school board they were floating
holidays so I think that there can be
some
flexibility already as it exists in
practice and in in uh
rules represent M thank you Madame chair
sorry to come in late uh but my two
cents is I think juneth holiday how many
other states at the school level and I
know in Massachusetts it's a holiday uh
and if it moves the last day of school
by one day because I know my spouse
Works in that so but that is one of the
things that they've acknowledged just
like New Hampshire was the last to adopt
civil liberty day or Martin Luther King
day as a holiday at least I'm glad that
we acknowledge juneth as a day of
recognizing the contribution the
African-American or black uh Community
have done in the history and this is
something to look at down the line I
respect the committee's due diligence on
how it's done but it's to be coming down
this line I just would like to see how
many other states acknowledge it already
all right thank you representative Dolan
and then sh thank you madam chair um
I I am becoming increasingly concerned
about the quality of our education in
terms of our as ident as represented by
our test scores we seem to be dropping
in this state lower and lower in with
comparison to other countries in the
world so if this gets translated into
another day off from school and I'm not
not saying that it would but if it does
then it's going to continue to hurt I
think our kids ability to demonstrate uh
their educational uh uh prowers so what
I would feedback I would give back to
the Senate uh on this is that if
somewhere in the legislation should be I
would recommend it be acknowledged that
if this results in a in a day off from
school that the School departments
around the state ought to consider
swapping some other day so maybe they
take a day from the April vacation week
or the February vacation week so that in
total the students don't lose a day it
just gets swapped out and that way our
education may be preserved uh in the
total number of hours uh in front of
their teachers so I I would I would
offer that that that this this pool of
days that potentially are off is not
endless and uh we we I think we need to
take take a stand and say that the
children's education comes first and the
memory of of whatever we're celebrating
uh whatever holiday it might be is is
come second and that uh so I would
encourage the sponsors of this bill to
give that some thought to to how they
would want to implement something like
this thank you represent I'm sh it thank
you madam chair um mindful of what
represent ative Dolan was just saying uh
I'm also aware that by putting into that
part of the statute uh we would create
the conundrum as to whether state
employees should have that day off and
whether they'd have to swap that out for
another day uh because that the number
of days they are allowed has been
limited uh and due to the fact that the
state did already chapter this as an
annual
celebration uh I think I I'm not quite
ready to take this step so I will be
voting for itl also thank you
representative
Smith um Madam chair thank you um I I
think that some of the holidays that we
have could be like St Patrick's Day a
great celebration for whatever the
holiday is but it does not close
municipal
offices schools are not closed
everything is open it's just those that
want to celebrate celebrate can
celebrate and I think maybe this is
another example of the same type of
holiday acknowledge it certainly and uh
even talk about it in schools and
newspapers articles or whatever but not
close the municipal offices schools
whatever that's my two cents all right
thank you representative Simon thank you
madam chair Just One Last angle on this
uh conversation um because I do think
that the point of contention is just on
the closing down of municipal offices
State offices and things of that nature
um the more that we do that I I think we
underappreciate sometimes the effect
that that has on on the working public
um and businesses that usually have to
continue working those holidays because
they can't afford to close down uh and
they're the ones actually paying the
taxes that pay for the people who are
now getting another paid day off to
celebrate a holiday that they're not
able to and uh you know in the retail
world that uh that weighs on you a
little bit after a while um and so I
agree I think that the the celebration
being in the public eye people
appreciating the day for what it is and
celebrating the day for what it is uh
but not not furthering the disparity
really between um the government's
ability to take another day off uh when
the rest of the public pretty much has
to continue working because they can't
afford to close another day of business
so uh for that reason I'll also be
voting itl anyone else represent Brown
uh thank you madam chair just kind of
following up on representative groda uh
as so as a former state employee you're
probably sick of me saying that but I
would guess that if if the union
discovered there was another official
holiday they would try to add that to
the list of the 10,000 state employees
days off I don't know if there's a limit
on on the number of those they can
actually have but I I would okay I would
agree with representative Simon that we
want to minimize the closure of our
state offices and Town Offices as much
as we can there's enough uh federal
holidays that we we notice only because
we don't get mail delivered that day
yeah right and followup follow up on on
the history so looking at at the law now
I'm guessing you're talking about 2019
the government chist
Proclamation calling for the proper
observance does there do we know what
that means I'm sure some of you know
what proper observance means or am I
thinking too
uh well it it was the day juneth was the
day the Emancipation Proclamation and
was
dist spread out and people were notified
of it so it's a day of
emancipation and so um we'll see how the
schools and other people will be able to
celebrate if they're still on
session represent Nolan thank you madam
chair for recognizing for an additional
comment uh if I could amend amend to the
comment I made earlier about the days
off of school and the impact to our
students uh when if this does result in
a day off from school then there are
endless number of parents that're going
to say I need to take the day off also
because I don't want my students home
alone and therefore there is a there is
a somewhat hidden economic impact act uh
across the state with parents not going
to work or having to take the day off to
uh to supervise their their their
children that have the day up so I just
want to add that thank you gold just
briefly at the risk of my colleague
beside
me getting
upset anyway I want to follow up on what
representative Simon said and I will say
that uh though I've had some brief
employment opportunities in kind of
official offices my husband and I have
always been self-employed and um so when
you're a farmer when you're a country
person when you're a logger when you're
just out not a part of the whole
holidays Monday through Friday work day
um you have a day you have business you
have to do you think oh I I need to get
to the post office or I need to get to
the bank or I need to get here it really
is disruptive to to have offices closed
and you don't know what the schedule is
and what these things are although I
have we have neighbors who um we love
dearly that have come here from India
and they throw do fireworks what for the
holidays in India and it's been just
delightful to learn what the holidays in
India are so maybe if we get something
where in the United States we all do
fireworks for every holiday People Like
Us who aren't tuned in we'll have a way
to find out I thought i' end with a
little humor well there are there are
people in my district that apparently
use fireworks to celebrate Friday
night much to the amusement of their
neighbors anyone else
comments all right the motion is in
expedient to legislate by representative
gr and the clerk can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative
Dolan clerk votes yes representative
voyd yes represent Brown yes represen
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representive
Shu yes representative
Davis
yes representative Fitz Patrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith representative and py yes and the
chair
yes 15 y z um yeah 15 yay zero nay sorry
okay the motion passes 15 to Zer is
there any objection to
consent okay we'll put it on consent
corre correction it's uh 16 16
oh 16 to zero all right thank you very
much okay we'll put that on
conern and we have five minutes before
our next
hearing doesn't like the next
one we'll
see
one
probably yes it
yes it
isn't sure if everyone's in agreement no
no no there's there's
people
e
e e
I'm opening the hearing on Senate Bill
373 and I call Representative
Bas thank you uh for the record my uh
name is Tony luckus I represented
Hillsboro 38 the towns of Lichfield and
Hudson um so I'm introducing House Bill
373 relative to the State Building Code
I'm just introducing it in lie of anyone
else here and I'm not prepared to answer
any
questions okay fair
enough oh excuse me you think you were
going to introduce
it I don't have
it it's
downt pardon
us daily forette for Senator
avard
tin these things they
happen
okay uh good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Daley fette and I'm the Senate majority
caucus director uh Senator avard was
unable to be here to introduce his bill
so he asked me to do it on his behalf
Senate Bill 373 is amended proposes a
modification to the State Building Code
specifically adjusting the maximum air
exchange rate in new homes from the
current threshold of three air exchanges
per hour to no more than five air
exchanges per hour it wasn't that long
ago that the air exchange rate was set
to seven per hour and was adjusted to
three as an experiment on Home
Efficiency the experiment has been a
failure and has caused a lot of
unintended consequences in particular
when it comes to health air exchange is
a critical component in maintaining the
health comfort and safety of Home
environments home homes accumulate
various po pollutants including dust pet
dander pollen and a multitude of organic
and chemical compounds coming from
cleaning products Furnishings paints and
other household
items even routine activities such as
cooking bathing and indoor drying of
clothes can significantly increase
indoor moisture levels without adequate
air exchange this moisture can
contribute to mold growth and structural
damage over time numerous health
organizations such as the CDC the EPA
and the American Lung Association have
indicated that an air exchange rate of
three times per hour is very restrictive
and limits at home's ability to breathe
adequately also the current threshold of
three air exchanges per hour presents
considerable challenges for home
builders this standard is so difficult
to achieve that new homes are routinely
failing their exchange tests meaning
that structural modifications may be
needed or more insulation which which
increases the cost of home construction
and creates more Del is sb373 will help
make homes safer and healthier as well
as more affordable to our constituents
um Senator avar asked me to do this on
his behalf but I believe there is some
folks here from the Home Builders
Association who would be able to better
answer any questions that you may have
thank you will not ask any
questions thank you very
much William mckenny
good morning member Madam chair and
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me to speak before you today so
New Hampshire building officials I'm
bill mckenny president of New Hampshire
building officials Association so the
New Hampshire building officials uh did
not support the original version of
Senate Bill 373 uh nor do we support the
amended language that we have before us
now Senate B Senate Bill 373 proposes to
amend the international conservation uh
energy conservation code 2018 Edition
for only one specific section pertaining
to residential dwellings this bill is an
attempt to amend the State Building Code
and also circumventing the New Hampshire
building code review board that is
established by the state legislature and
charge with providing a single package
of codes with mutually agreed upon
amendments to be ratified the
requirement for three air changes per
hour has been in effect in the state of
New Hampshire since March 15th of 202 22
under the 2015 editions of the codes
training of code officials and
contractors to this requirement began at
least six months prior to the effective
date and continues to be part of our
regular training
programs why go backwards now and and
add create and create more
confusion an amendment can be proposed
to the building code review board next
session they can do it annually now we
have a we have the processes in place to
do that and follow the appropriate
process through the New Hampshire
building code review board there has
been there has been no significant
reduction in residential dwellings being
built because of three air changes per
hour in fact many communities continue
to see increased residential
construction to meet the demand for
housing amending individual code
sections through legislation is not wise
this ties the hands of the New Hampshire
building code review board the
amendments are often much more difficult
to locate
and as as industry standards and codes
evolve conflicts can often arise between
what is permitted by the adopted code
and what is permitted by Statute New
Hampshire building officials Association
does not support individual amendments
to codes through
legislation the New Hampshire building
code review board and their
subcommittees spent many months
reviewing the package of codes and
amendments that is proposed in House
Bill 1059 including the 2000 excuse me
energy code the package was supported by
a majority vote of the 17 member code
review
board although not all stakeholders
agree with all aspects of the code
package that is presented in House Bill
1059 The Proposal represents months of
stakehold month of stakeholder input at
public hearings work sessions and
compromise to adopt a package of codes
that is best for New Hampshire New
Hampshire building officials Association
ask this committee to not support Senate
Bill 373 and to support the codes and
amendments the New Hampshire building
code review board has proposed in House
Bill
1059 thank you and I will welcome any
questions thank you represent man py
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um how does this
compare to the time when we had pandemic
and the a exchange became a very
critical part of keeping the communities
healthy the parts per unit uh exchange
is this more relaxed or less
sting
I I think it improves on the energy code
side of it and you know um giving better
benefits to the to the building owners
the homeowners um again you know uh less
air exchanges um an
hour
could result in
unhealthier air if you don't have proper
filtration thank
you I have a question this five is this
five air
changes per
hour yes is what they're proposing and
okay and that is with whatever
ventilation is established in the in the
building correct so that if you have
um air air air vents or fans or um air
heat recovery U air exchangers you would
that is part of the Baseline that you
use when you're testing to see if you
meet three correct okay thank you
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair morning
Bill so the I I've gotten a number of
communications from Builders and so
forth and so on talking about the
science that too many uh to buildings
that are too tight are unhealthy uh that
you it promotes the the the development
of of mold and and and so forth and so
on now obviously every exch Exchange in
the wintertime is mixed pickles right uh
win some lose some because because you
get better air you're also paying for
heating the outside instead of the
inside of your house so the question I
have is where's the science on this
because obviously in the summertime you
can open all your windows and you got
permanent regular uh constant air
exchange right uh and and then you want
to have your windows closed potentially
because it's too damned hot outside
right so it's a bad attle against you
know two different factors uh constantly
so where's the science on this in terms
of what would be optimal without being
too expensive either in the summer or
the winter for that
matter very very good question uh and I
first would like to say that the
Hampshire building officials Association
is not opposed to the five air changes
per hour what we're opposed to is the
process that's being taken right now to
circumvent the building code review
board to answer your question
representative Schmidt uh the science is
again I guess it depends on which side
of the argument you're on um you can do
heal um healthy homes with the air
exchange hour at three but again it be
comes down to a balance of humidity in
the home um if you if you ow if you
allow too much humidity in your home you
use your humidifier too much you bring
that level up you we're going to start
to have M and mold home because at three
air air exchanges per hour if you're
keeping your your humid humidity at the
correct levels so that your air exchange
and humidity levels are balancing out
then you have less risk of
that okay thank you representative Brown
uh thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question so
um I you noted in early on that this
change to three air exchanges was due to
the change in the conservation code um
do you remember the history of what was
supposed to be the benefit to
conservation by going to three times a
exchange versus
5 it would be mostly on the energy
conservation okay so um if you recall on
the prior codes prior to 2015 it was
seven air changes per hour in the 2015
codes um we had it called for three air
changes for hour which was a drastic
jump and and at the time we did a phased
in process with a Sunset date of um
March 15 of 2022 to kind of phase in
that drop uh as I understand it the 2021
energy codes now reverts that air
exchange back to five um but as you see
we are not adopting the 2021 energy code
we're adopting we're we're staying with
the 2018 so again because this comes in
kind of late in the process it didn't go
through building code review board the
way it should have or if it did I
believe it was it was not approved um
they had a majority vote not to approve
the amendment to the building code
review board and leave it as written in
the 2018 codes thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um so your
testimony is that your major concern is
the process that it's going through not
necessarily the outcome of the process
is am I understanding you correctly that
is correct follow up followup um so my
question and maybe you can clarify this
for me the way that the system is set up
presently was it not put in place that
way to assist the legislature and doing
the job of adopting code and that even
though the building code review board
goes through their process every single
time that code still has to come to us
for our ultimate review and adoption and
at that time we could change whatever we
wanted to um at that point um that's my
understanding of it so how would be how
would this be any different than
that that's a very good question too um
but you're correct the process you know
in my view from the building officials
the process should always begin with the
building code review board and are
amendments proposed as the process goes
through the legislature absolutely but
that is the process that we all have to
work with and uh again I just believe
that when we start putting language such
as five air changes hour in specifically
in legislation rather than in an
amendment through the building code
review board it's much more difficult to
amend later on whereas a bu a an
amendment can go right back through the
building code review board at any time
and be proposed to
you represent man thank you madam chair
just another quick follow up so 1056
pass the building code through house HB
105 6 would it be possible to amend that
and add this amendment to that adopting
the new building code uh 2018 building
code or 2021 whichever one we are going
to adopt is that a
possible
solution yes if the building codes that
are proposed are adopted in this session
it's absolutely possible for an
amendment to be proposed for next
session through follow the process
through the building code review board
as it
should Mr mckenley do you know if this
specific amendment was brought to the
building code review
board was it I mean was was this issue
rejected by the building code review
board or simply
overlooked as I recall this was
discussed with the building code review
board um and and it the vote for the
building code review board was uh uh 12
against one
for um ah so that the building code
review board looked at this amendment
and voted one to 12 against
correct I just don't believe there was
if I may I just don't believe there was
a a strong enough argument made um
between all parties to convince the
building code review board the need for
the
change okay thank you very much much any
other questions representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair well I I I I'm
fully in favor of the building code
rward having a major role to play
because you guys are the most expert
group that we have to to get at the
nitty-gritty and make good decisions for
us to then ratify um I I I I am troubled
by the idea that possibly we have a good
result but a bad process in this
instance
so uh so but the thing is I also agree
with you that locking some things into
statute is not a good idea because it's
as you stated more difficult to undo a
bad decision uh if it's in statute and
you have to do it because the statute
says you can't do it any other way or
whatever so uh so you're coming before
us and saying that you want this
rejected based on science and process as
well I
would yes we we would like this not
supported by the committee um primarily
because of process you know and New
Hampshire building officials Association
is absolutely willing to work with the
sponsor um to help them and and work
with them through the process with the
building code review board and actually
get our support for this in the next
session okay thank you represent Simon
question of the chair just to give Mr
mckin a break
I said some hard questions um ultimately
all code goes into statute because
that's what we do when we adopt the code
so it all ends up in statute this would
also end up in statute so my question
would be the next time uh that Mr
Sherman or somebody else brings us uh
the updated code and we and we vote on
that code would that make this law
obsolete or would it be outside of the
code um what what we do statute is to
say we adopt adopt the Amendments
approved by the building code review
board up through a point in
time so if that code addressed this
issue it would override this piece of
legislation and Implement that um that's
a very good question because if it did
then it would be the same exact process
that we're doing right now right okay
anyone else thank you thank you Mr
mckenley Matt Mayberry thank you very
much
good morning
still there we go start
again good morning my name is Matt
Mayberry I'm the Executive Vice
President of New Hampshire homebuilders
Association and we're very much in
favor of increasing the air exchanges
from 3 to five and we'll talk a little
bit about
that we represent or I represent our 500
members which in turn reflects the
36,000 men and women in New Hampshire
who work in the Residential Building
Trades you've heard from some of them um
but here to fill in the
blanks representative s and I'm going to
start right off the bat by saying I
agree with
you outside committees can make
recommendations they can review but you
folks are the policy
deciders you set the policy no outside
board does that you folks
do and we're in disagreement with the
building code review board
because I won't let you see all the
sausage being made but the air exchanges
was part of a little Poli
football that tied back to the energy
codes and they were mad at
us so that's a little little Insider
game for you but when achang is and what
they do is they'll go into a
home close up the home open up a door
and put a
large kind of almost like a tarp over a
the door with a fan that will pull all
of the a a out of the
house then a calculation is done how
many times per hour is that air replaced
in the home that has been
removed currently it's
three it's extremely
hard to do that and I have two stories
for you regarding
that my Builders are telling me that
when this first started out a few years
ago it was seven air exchanges per hour
the legislature and the state and the
building code review board said let's
try three let's see if this will work
let's see if it helps with Energy
Efficiency let's see if it works for
what we want the answer is no it's not
working there's a question about some of
the science behind
this the CDC the EPA the American Lung
Association Harvard Public Health
and the World Health
Organization along with the friendly
neighborhood home builder Association
say it's not working at
all I
approached a a matter of fact
the
um the American Society of heating
refrigerating and air conditioning
Engineers that was founded in
1959 in their findings they found that
only 8% of us homes are able to achieve
three air exchanges per
hour that number goes up to
23% when you do
five let's not forget that the five that
we're requesting is
still lower than what it was originally
at seven it still produces a tight home
an energy efficient home but also an
affordable home my Builders can do
that I push my Builders about coming and
testifying before you today so you
didn't hear from
me uh two of them I've renamed them
Patrick and
Brett they didn't want to come before
you
folks because they would talked about
how the sausage was really made out in
the
field one of the builders built his own
home has an asmatic son here's a
doctor's note he worked with the
building
official in the town when he built his
home and he said if I make this three
air exchanges per
hour my son is going to have a hard time
breathing all the reports are showing
increase of respiratory issues mold
milde moisture in the home homes need to
breathe a little
bit he worked with the building
official and said what do I what can I
do about
this the building off told
him you have a
choice we can work together just kind of
shake hands go forward build your
house or create three exchanges in your
home whatever it takes to get
that when you get your certificate of
occupancy his quote not mine go put a
hole in the side of the building and put
a
vent so you increase those air exchanges
what they're not telling you is that
with the three air exchanges you have a
hard time in an issue with propane
heating natural gas heating and wood
stoves Patrick told me a story of that
when he built his home to the three air
exchanges put in a wood
stove it was releasing carbon monoxide
into the home because not enough fresh
air was coming in he had to spend an
extra
$5,000 to put in a fresh air system
system so his wood stove could ventilate
and operate
properly again more added costs coming
across
the I hate want to lose my train of
thought
sorry but ladies and gentlemen what
we're asking you to do is please
compromise on five air exchanges per
hour the 2021 energy codes that many in
this room are
advocating
support and bring forward five air
exchanges even the iecc said that three
was too
tight so this does have an impact we're
willing to work with everyone
representative you are very correct that
when it goes into statute it gets looped
into the next time we change the codes
it just gets picked up within there you
folks are the policy deciders not a
review board
and I'll take any questions thank you
are there
questions represent
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking
questions can you tell me
when this issue was brought before the
building code review
board about a year ago maybe a year and
a half ago or so
and it hasn't been brought forward in
between that time frame a year and a
half ago when now I think it first came
forward
as the home builders Express concern
that they can't meet these three air
exchanges and asked us to bring it
forward through the building code Review
Board in this latest
update to the what is possibly
potentially the 2021 building code
uh so it was brought to my attention
about a year maybe a year and a half ago
representative then we did an amendment
that was brought forward to the building
code review
board
H all right because I'm I'm just have an
issue
with bypassing process we've set here in
the state and going before the building
code review board and
I understand
the issues you're having and I feel for
that because I think three exchanges
isn't enough
but since a time frame of the
three and understanding that five is in
the 2021 I would
hope that you folks can get this settled
within the next year through the correct
process that we have set instead of
coming here to the legislature for
something like this um because I I I I
and the question
is would you be willing to do
that of course the New Hampshire
homebuilder Association brought for to
the building code review board I think
it was five or six amendments that we
would like to see within the building
code when the home builders came out and
I will just be
direct when the home builders came out
against the 2021 energy code
there were a lot of folks on the
building code review board who are
pretty cranky about
that and so the
12:1 the one was the home builder member
because we get one seat on there The
Architects the engineers and all the
others who really wanted the 21 energy
codes they were pretty mad at me so I
won't say it's
retribution it's kind of coincidental we
come out against the 21 energy code and
every sing single idea the home builders
brought forward was
denied thank you for explaining the
sausage representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair and
thanks for taking my question so if only
8% Across the Nation can achieve this
what happens to the builders in New
Hampshire what happens if you don't
achieve this if you can't achieve three
then what happens to the home the the
buyer the Builder and and the
owner they spend more money closing up
the house again and again and again
until they can get two
three this was a a nationwide survey but
in New Hampshire where I've heard from
my Builders is they're doing things such
as before the blower door test they're
not installing carpet because as you
know in a four side air system just the
the pile of the the carpet pushes up the
vent so air can come back
in so they're not putting it in the
carpet going on to subfloor doing their
blower drawer test okay now we can go go
put the carpet in what's happening
representative is you're
having from what I've been
told they're doing what they need to do
to get to number
three when they get their
certificate then they do what they need
to do to finish the home thank you
followup I me one followup yes thank you
um how much does it cost so every time
they rework the house they have to pay
for a test again or did the contractors
do that themselves or hire that out and
what does that cost um they're saying
it's adding about $3,000 for every
missed
test representative Mani thank you madam
chair I'm just having a hard time
wrapping my head
around on one hand it's the safety
well-being health of the individuals
living or working in a building that is
why the code is to help a healthy living
condition on the other hand you're
telling me that the home builders are
versus Home Builders Association or
building code Association there's a
friction so who's suffering at the end
of the day is the granite Staters who
are
building
and so how is the Builders
Association doing what they're doing to
help their customers to say your Healthy
Living is important and how can we work
isn't that the part of the Builder and
you know there's a code and isn't that
part of the role that you play yes ma'am
and that's why I'm
here we're representing those home
buyers who are having potentially
respiratory issues who have children who
are asthmatic who having issues with
heating the home how they choose
to be it propane natural gas or wood or
any combination thereof and Electric
so you're correct we're here at because
we will build the homes to code and if
we have to get to three air exchanges
per hour then they
will but then they could be telling the
consumer when you go in the
house kind like your mom did all those
years ago she was correct open up a
window so any Energy savings is
literally going out the window now
because you're trying to get some air in
there there was a project in which
federal money was involved it was for
low-income
housing the Builder went in built to
three air exchanges got the
approvals then had to go back into each
of the units and put in a small about
almost a baseball size
vent with a little lever that the tenant
could open it up to let some fresh air
into their home because it was just too
tight thank you representative BR has a
question so the um five exchange is part
of the 2021 energy code yes follow up
follow up and is there any other part of
the code that you want were willing to
adopt we have to look at it more ma'am I
don't have it I wasn't prepared to
answer that question today but when we
talked about the 2018 versus 21 energy
codes the home builder Association had
asked we're willing to
compromise on that 21 energy code and we
were informed three times All or
nothing I asked there are some things we
like like the air exchange and that's
why we kind of waited that's what we
went outside the
process there are things we like in the
21 codes but when you given all or
nothing that's what we're instructed
okay thank you other questions represent
baay thank
you am I to understand that the this
international code originally said three
and that the new code will be
five why have they decided to move from
three to
five CDC EPA Harvard Public Health
Health W World Health Organization
they're all saying we have to go to
five thank
you thank you very much Mr you have
another question
fromy
one thank you madam chair for your
Indulgence thank you for taking my
question in terms of
2021 building code which in know
building builders association totally
opposed the energy code wasn't part of
the climate change the world Health all
those supported that too in terms of
energy code so how is that different now
just one piece of
it anywhere between $20,000 and
$94,000 made the difference in that
because yes we liked aspects of the 21
energy
codes but not things that would cost the
consumer and place Consumer Debt onto
the backs of home buyers between 20,000
and $94,000 depending if appendix a was
adopted by the state or municipalities
or not so agree with you we found things
we liked we found things we wanted to do
but we were
instructed as in order to get the
federal money that some people have
wanted it was all or nothing nothing no
changes thank you
sorry thank you for your testimony thank
you mam chair thank you committee Philip
Sherman thank you madam chair members of
the committee I had hoped to sit on my
hands today
but if I can go back through a couple of
questions and points that have been
raised um I'll start with the last one
that there were no changes there are in
fact changes to the 2018 energy code are
amendments that are still in effect so
we've already mucked with that code a
little bit we simply proposed to stay
with the code the way it was um the vote
as Mr Mayberry indicated was was 12 to
one um and I think the general sense was
that much of the public testimony from
the American Institute of Architects uh
this organization NE which is a national
Energy Group that I I forget the name of
it uh was if you're gonna if you're GNA
give up on the 2021 code don't
cherry-pick the nice stuff that's in
there stay with the 18 code the way you
have it basically so I I don't think it
was the sense of the board as much as
the sense of the uh testimony which then
led to the vote of the
board um I want to rewind back to a
question that or more a comment that was
made I don't believe of the 17 members
on the building code review board
there's anybody that questions the
authority of the general court we are
fully aware and we remind each other
frequently of the hierarchy that that we
live within uh and I'm per speaking for
myself I'm not at all uncomfortable with
that I don't
need bureaucrats call it writing rules
without the Public's representative is
having a having a a very loud say so
however
um if I can put words in my own mouth I
would hope that the general Court's view
of what we do is to sort of reserve the
right for a veto rather than to write
the stuff themselves this does come
through a model code process and then
massaged by the people on the building
code review board with the expertise to
deal with this and then to the general
court just to make sure that we're not
getting out of line um
now let me get to one other point and
then I'll focus on the problem and maybe
offer a
solution uh the other question was
whether this amends the 2018 code and
the answer is yes the way this is
written we're required to write an
amendment to the 2018 ICC so if in some
point in the future the 28 code is not
the state energy code anymore we'll
still be writing amendments to some code
that doesn't matter and this bill would
need to be relooked at and and fiddled
with at that point now my proposed
solution and I don't know if it fits in
with the general court schedule we have
a meeting coming up in may we have
another meeting coming up on June
14th um we would have the ability if the
home builder so chose uh for them to
resubmit that Amendment at our May
meeting we could have the public hearing
vote on the 14th of June it would
require once again changing the date in
HB
1059 uh it's 1059 not
1056 um to June
14th we're already in need of changing
it to May anyway so the only question is
whether that leaves uh you all and our
all the other people that come into the
mix enough time to to deal with that um
and at that point I guess somebody could
decide to just pass this bill Bill if we
deny it again or get rid of the bill if
we approve that amendment I do think I
have a copy of the amendment that was
submitted and the justification
consisted of three words reduction in
requirements um the testimony at the
public hearing was heavily in favor of
staying with the 2018 code given what Mr
Mayberry testified this morning they may
want to add more to that or bring in
others uh to to inform the board more
than we were informed the first
time so I don't know if that works but
that would be one way to get out of this
Jam thank you are there any questions
representative leus and then go over
thank you um so I I'm trying to I'd like
to know what the justification is for
just deciding that you're not going to
cherry pick it it's not clear what the
reason is I thought the the purpose of
the board was to make judgment calls and
it would seem like if there are good
things in the new code why wouldn't the
board consider accepting them it sounds
like they was just rejected for offand
almost if if what I heard is the
case we as you as everybody else are are
trying to find a balance between one
part of society that thinks the more
regulations on energy the better and
other parts that are saying it costs too
much it impacts housing and all the
other things that go into the mix um so
don't believe that it was a a shoot from
the hip decision at all but this was
worked out over many many sessions and
the and the the premise started with
writing lots of amendments to the 2021
code in order to make it sort of equal
to 2018 code that resulted I think in 54
additional amendments that were needed
to our process it was going to just
break the back of the process so the
decision was to just stay with the 2018
code uh but at that
point that that side of the argument if
you will had already gotten the majority
of what they wanted so I think there
were people on the board that just said
you know you you've got that much we're
still trying to find some kind of a it's
never going to be a consensus but at
least some meeting in the middle here uh
there was another amendment and that is
that the that the 2021 code changes
marac County to a less restricted
climate zone because it's getting warmer
um and that also was turned down but it
wasn't submitted back as a bill here um
so yeah we could write our own energy
code and sort of start from scratch but
that's not how new hure is done it to
this point all right thank
you I'm shocked to hear that the
building C review board is a political
body representative
Goldie thank you madam chair and
just a quick because I saw you know on
your head when I asked about the change
from the seven exchanges to the three
when that was made and if you could just
go over that time frame and how long the
three exchanges has been in place so I
looked that up this morning before I
came just so I had it with me uh the
2009 series of international codes came
into effect in April of
2010 in New Hampshire uh that set the
seven air changes I don't I didn't look
at what happened before that uh 2015 for
those of you who are around remember was
a bit of a tussle getting those codes
accepted is that putting it politely
enough um and that resulted in a series
of amendments that were deferred and
they triggered on March of
2022 so on March of
2022 we're on the 15 code still was
amended to seven and then it reverted to
the base code in March of 22 to three
then when we came to the 18 code in July
of 2022 it still was three so this this
threee change requirement has been in
effect in New Hampshire since March of
2022 four year or two years um the model
code has reverted it went from seven
then it went to three for a couple of
additions now it's going to five so
somebody out there thinks that there's a
problem with the three I'm not here to
speak about the sign sence everybody
seems to have their own science on these
things but uh somebody at the model code
level thinks that five is a better
number than
three um so as with Bill McKenna I'm
here more talking about the
process I think representative Schmidt
put it well it's it's perhaps a good
answer with a bad process um or or a
less desirable process let's put it that
way thank you any other other
questions repres
time thank you madam chair um I'm in
agreement and and that I want to be
careful how we proceed with process
because what we don't want is 25
amendments coming to this committee um
all asking to override the decision of
the the review board um how and we'll
have two already this year uh the 21
energy code and then this this request
here however I want to be able to
balance that with not just becoming a
rubber stamp for the building code
review board where we don't take up
anything uh that's contradictory to the
board's findings because that's not our
job our job is to actually review what
you've done and make a sound decision on
it so I am still struggling and there's
a question I promise I am still
struggling to find that that balance in
this situation where somebody didn't
like it and we've been asked to pick it
up
um you have mentioned potentially going
back to the building code review board
with an amendment to address this issue
um
but but where does it where in that
process would we would fit the idea that
well this is just what the legislative
body wants to do whether the building
code review board wants it done that way
or not so if you go back and you have
the conversation and the building code
review board decides that they don't
want to do this but the legislative body
decides that it does or vice versa um
what's what's the benefit then at that
point of going back to you for the
process I'm I'm trying to balance bance
those things and figure that out the
benefit would only be the Cho the chance
that the building code review board
would change their mind and and approve
this amendment it would be a resubmittal
of the amendment that was previously
submitted in August of last year um with
better backup
justification one quick followup follow
um because as I'm listening to testimony
I I feel like what I'm hearing is
sometimes we get a little bit p ized in
our understanding of issues and we get
locked into our way of thinking um
thinking that one way is a solution when
it's really not a total solution so on
the one side we can locked into the idea
that um by lowering the code standards
and having seven or eight they we
actually saving people money because
then you're literally just blowing heat
out the door and expenses actually going
up over time um so that's not
necessarily the case or the other
direction just tightening and tightening
and tightening is good um so would it be
safe to characterize the conversation
with when it comes to these things it's
a bell curve we're looking for The Sweet
Spot in between the tightness of the
home and the affordability and that at
some point we're going to fall off the
horse on either on either side would
that be a that be a way of illustrating
it from your perspective I'm just trying
to understand that a little
bit I don't know okay this is a this is
a societal discussion that's going on
way out here and we're a little piece of
it uh we're not going to resolve
society's
discussion thank you appreciate that
answer other
questions representative gold thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question and please forgive my dyslexic
mind trying to Grapple with
this I keep flopping back and
forth can you just keep it simple for
the stupid and explain
how what is the difference between 3
five and seven like is this about money
is this about health is this like what
is the why would we go I I'm confused
the answer to the first part of your
question I don't know if I can keep it
simple but I'll try uh this is a leakage
test it's like blowing up a balloon they
put a fan in the door and they
pressurize the building and they see how
much air leaks out and I understood that
part so more air leaking out means you
can have more cracks for instance let's
just call it that more leaks less air
means you've got to construct it tighter
so all of that goes into the I don't
know how many different pieces there are
in a typical house but it's got to be
seven figures by nails and 2x4s and this
all these things have to come together
old windows cracks where the walls more
seiling and as Mr Mayberry indicated
that the the mechanics of actually doing
the test uh I keep hearing about the the
uh HVAC the air conditioning vents under
the kitchen cabinet or the bathroom
cabin cabinet now those are a problem um
it it increases the amount of detail
work that a contractor has to do to seal
up this
house not to be rud but Madam can I
follow up to help clarify what I'm
trying to understand is the numbers my
dyslexia is with
numbers three five and seven what's
better what's worse why is there a
difference what your criteria is the
tighter the house is the less energy you
will need to heat or cool it so that so
that you want to have as little air
leakage as possible to minimize the
amount of energy so they went if you if
you go with more leakage it also
produces more fresh air and it doesn't
seal in the contaminants so that's what
the the issue is lower is a better
number is it tighter number if it was
Zero there would be no leakage at all so
can I just state to try to understand
clearly so we had seven which meant
fresher air but more energy leakage and
that's where we're getting into the
political bigger and then we went down
to five and then we went down to three
but now at three though it's doing the
energy thing maybe that some purists
whatever you want to say like it's
causing some health issues issues so
that's bringing in some and you're all
caught in the middle of all that
controversy and that's why we're being
asked to look at this we we went from
seven to three and then the model codes
and this proposed bill go back to
five um okay I don't know why the model
code changed that some of it may have
been Health arguments the CDC weighs in
there somewhere uh and some of it may be
constructibility
arguments representative Schmid you have
a question thank you m
here so I empathize with everybody here
because life is a confusing series of
successive approximations as we used to
say in in music we're going to sing an
approximat um but how about older
buildings because most of the most of
the housing and buildings have been
there for a long time my home my
building has been there for over a
hundred years and uh so to the degree
that we
are you can thank all of us we're here
heating the outdoors in the winter time
and uh we're cooling the outdoors in the
summer time but uh where are they are
older buildings inherently more friendly
to the health of the occupant but more
unfriendly to their
pocketbook uh so because we have to
think about them too
I guess I would just ask some of us are
of a certain age is how many people with
asthma did we know when we were children
not that many um in terms of existing
buildings though again the energy code
doesn't come into play at all until you
do a project till you alter it change
the occupancy or whatever and at that
point basically what you do you do by
the new code so I replace a window or
whatever it is is and there are some
significant exceptions in the energy
code for work in existing buildings I
open up a wall I only have to put in how
much insulation will fit for instance
and other exceptions to that ilk and New
Hampshire expanded those exceptions
which were designed for alterations to
what we refer to as changes of occupancy
so somebody wants to change that office
building back to a residence those
exceptions would now now work we got
that done last year so there are
significant Provisions that relax this
stuff for uh existing buildings
represent follow just to followup so but
you're still coming before us e echoing
Mr McKenna's recommendation to vote no
on this Bill yes thank you that's
correct all right any other
questions thank you very much thank you
does anyone else wish to testify on
Senate Bill 37
3 all right I will close the
hearing and we have another hearing
starting at
1:15
e
e e
good
afternoon welcome to Edna sorry about
the ventilation we've been working on
that on the building our last
fille all
right I would uh we have four guests
from the Health and Human Services
committee with us today who are who will
be able to give us some more
information and possibly ask
questions so I'm opening the hearing on
Senate Bill 440 and I call the prime
sponsor Senator Ward
thank you Madame chair and the members
of the
committee um Ruth W representing
District 8 and I'm here today with the
testimony for Senate Bill
440 doctors of automaty in New Hampshire
concurrently practice only what the
statute specifically
allows this puts the legislator in the
position of making clinical
decisions I believe the time has come
for doctors of automet to be treated in
the Statue like other doctor level care
providers s sp44 does just that in a
nutshell it authorizes the board of
Optometry to regulate the practice of
Optometry by determining the
qualifications of certain procedures and
provides a list of procedures excluded
from the practice of
Optometry based upon curricula from
schools of Optometry these doctors
attend and based upon many years of
Performing Advanced procedures in other
states the Senate believes that
experience and evidence clearly
demonstrates doctors of autometer are
fully capable of Performing Advanced
procedures
the Senate Edna committee unanimously
recommend passage with an amendment and
the bill passed the full Senate on a
Voice
vote s440 will eliminate the need for
new legislation each time there is a
change in curriculum this is important
to the citizens of our state as our
aging population and eye health issues
are outpacing
providers s SP 440 makes other updates
to the opom statute that will be
described in subsequent
testimony the map of authorized
procedures across the country makes no
sense Doctors of Optometry do not lose
or gain a capability when they cross
state lines it's time the regulatory
board of this profession like other
health care professions is allowed to
make these decisions based upon
Education and Training not
politics there are ample people
presenting testimony in FA of
h440 they can speak in more detail and
answer questions
fully on a personal note this issue
between Opthomologist and Optometry is
really nothing new that has existed
across many professional lines I think
of teachers and Par
professionals
anesthesiologists and nurse and
anesthetists there are a lot of areas
where the professions are sort of
overlapping but not quite and I think we
all work very well together regardless
what we do we work together for the best
for our patients that we are taking care
of thank you very
much thank you
Senator Senator if there are any
questions I think there are people
behind me that could better answer them
that's thank you that's what you said
and I'll take your your word for it
Senator
Susi thank you thank you very much Madam
chairman members of the committee for
the record I'm Donna Susi I represent
Senate District 18 which is the town of
Lichfield and five Wards in the city of
Manchester and I'm here testifying today
in support of Senate Bill 440 um a bill
that received uh a great deal of
attention in the Senate and a lot of
consideration um I'm appearing here for
two specific reasons and I know there
are a ton of experts that will get into
a lot of the more technical issues that
this bill contemplates but I think that
legislation is necessary and I do think
it's long overdue
um the medical profession typically
governs itself self through rules um
regarding scope of practice and in this
instance Optometry is almost totally
defined in statute making it a lot
harder to keep up with advances in
science medicine and even changes in
curriculum um that it provided at the
university college level um when these
practitioners are pursuing their
education there have been a number of
things that have been added to their
curriculum um that are procedures not
currently contemplated within the scope
of practice by the statute but I think
the other issue for me that is of
particular importance is access and
access to healthc care I think it's
something that we are all cognizant of
and that we all um strive to ensure our
constituents have proper access and in
this case um given the rati IO of the
two professions that we're talking about
I think there are many examples and some
of them you will hear today where people
have had to wait months for referrals to
another practitioner um and they have
been you know suffering with whatever
the condition is for a longer period of
time and they issues that could have
been treated by the optometrist at the
point that the patient
presents um particularly in rural areas
of our state that is increasingly a
problem um it's also a problem in places
like where I live in Manchester a large
city that has many
practitioners um specializing in this
field um there are people that are not
able to access this critical health care
and um your vision is something that is
so so critically important I mean I look
around this room how many folks are
wearing glasses uh I myself am wearing
contact lenses th this is truly
important and the procedures beyond that
that could easily be treated sooner and
closer to someone's home um are really
really important uh as I said you're
going to hear a lot more specific
examples so I don't want to go on but
the two key issues I think for for all
of us to consider is one that we treat
this profession a little differently
um and also that um early treatment in
many times for patients will save them
both time money um will also save them
from potential discomfort will also uh
ensure that they have the access to care
that we've come to expect and that we
hope we can provide in the state of New
Hampshire so with that I'll conclude my
testimony happy to answer any questions
as I said you're you're going to get a
lot more specificity following me so
thank you madam chair thank
you thank for your testimony very good
representative
pelli good
afternoon I am representative Susan
pelli Rockingham District 19 Hampton
Falls and Kensington
I support SB 440 as an important step in
expanding provider care for patients and
reducing wait times for specific Eye
Care
procedures currently significant wait
times for procedures that are only
available with an optomologist impact
Patient Care Doctors of Optometry are
trained to perform many of these
procedures in office all procedures
permitted by SB 440 are minor in office
procedures that have been taught in
Optometry schools for decades and are
not Advanced Eye
surgeries the current Optometry statute
is
outdated and the statutes should
regulate Doctors of Optometry similar to
the way other professions are regulated
which s440 does all other independent
doctorate level Medical professions in
New Hampshire have board autonomy and
are
self-regulated these other doctorate
level professional boards do not need to
continue to return to the
legislature and this extensive process
to update statutes as technology and
education advances
occur doctors wishing to perform these
procedures will need to display
competency through a process defined by
by the state regulatory board as is
standard across all Health Care boards
in New Hampshire no doctor will perform
such a procedure without extensive
education laboratory learning and
Hands-On supervised
experience this bill will update
outdated laws and result in reduced uh
decreased costs improve access to care
and provide patients with with much
needed
services on behalf of the Professionals
of Optometry practice I ask for passage
of this Bill thank
you thank
you okay thank you very
good all right to all the uh the experts
trying who are going to try and
Enlighten us on eye surgery in the next
next uh few minutes uh please U respect
our time and don't duplicate testimony
we have your written testimony in large
quantities and we do read
it uh
so you need and please don't read to us
that we are all there's a major test
before you can join the Edna committee
and and reading is one of the one of the
qualifications
so um so we will start with the
uh uh Christine
Donahue thank you madam chair members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today I'm
Dr Christine K and Donahue a second
generation new hampsh doctor of
Optometry born and raised in Bedford I
received my doctor of Optometry degree
from the New England College of
Optometry I'm a member of the New
Hampshire joint credentialing committee
and the current president of the board
of Optometry I am here today on behalf
of the board to support Senate Bill 440
and help highlight what the bill does
authorize and what it does not authorize
there are a few cleanup items in the
bill the first serves to dissolve The
Joint credentialing committee this is a
20-year-old committee that's been in
active since about 2020 as it has been
unnecessary and unneeded however should
it any functions be needed in the future
the Senate Bill 440 can transfer this
role to the board of
Optometry next decades ago Doctors of
Optometry in New Hampshire were
authorized to prescribe hi to codone
however because of a federal change in
classification systems our state statute
prevents us from prescribing that the
board supports maintaining its current
restriction on schedule to drve
however adding an exception for only a
72-hour with no refill supply of
hydrocodone the last cleanup item is the
continuing education requirements Senate
Bill 440 maintains the current 20 hours
of live classes every year and does
assign 10 of those hours specific to
ocular disease and pharmacology topics
the change only removes the independent
study requirements including the reading
of journals that are impossible to track
and verify
this change is in alignment with other
medical professionals including
dentistry and Podiatry here in New
Hampshire and consistent with Optometry
continuing education in other states now
I'd like to move on to some other
aspects of Senate Bill
440 most of what you'll be hearing about
today although Optometry is defined
nationally with a standard criteria for
Education and Training as you've heard
the scope of practice within each state
is dictated within each individual state
the current New Hampshire statute does
not give the board of Optometry any
autonomy to regulate what constitutes
our profession or adapt to advances in
it because of this our statute has
fallen well behind that of National
Training the main goal of Senate Bill
440 is regulatory to correct this
discrepancy and ensure that the citizens
of New Hampshire have access to
upto-date Eye Care both now and in the
future this bill will not allow the
board or its licenses to operate outside
the National Standard of Optometry the
autonomy that Senate Bill 440 would
allow the board of Optometry is well
established in New Hampshire as you've
heard from the wonderful um legislators
before me it's actually now the norm in
New Hampshire for doctoral Level Health
Care professions including Dentistry
Podiatry Pharmacy and physical therapy
all of these similar professions have
this Authority and we are asking to be
commensurate with them our board does
have a spotless record in regulation of
our profession demonstrating our
commitment to public health and safety
for over 113 years with passage of
Senate Bill 440 the board of Optometry
will use this National Standard to guide
optometry in New Hampshire through the
rul making process for example Doctors
of Optometry who have graduated recently
and have completed coursework lab
practice and clinical training required
will be granted certification
doctors who have practiced in states
where they performing the procedures
that you'll hear about today can be
granted certification other optometrists
who seek certification will take the
continuing education requirements
required by the board laid out through
rul making to demonstrate competency
before being granted
certification continuing education
process is used by healthc Care
Professionals we do not go back to
school or complete residency for
advancements within our own professions
fortunately some colleagues in organized
medicine including Opthalmology have
prioritized a national movement that
they call stop scope creep whose mission
is to block any legislation which would
Advance non-md Health Care Professionals
including not only Optometry but
psychology Pharmacy Podiatry and nurse
practitioners to name a few therefore
the our opposition will try to paint the
picture that this is not a regulatory
bill but rather sweeping scope bill
according to our opposition if you
approve this bill it will automatically
allow Doctors of Optometry to perform
Opthalmology published but inaccurate
list of 258 surgical codes this is not
true approximately 200 of their
presented codes will not be authorized
by Senate Bill 440 I have spent hours
pouring over this document and I was
shocked to see that it was distributed
to the legislature and to the public
that it is fact I can assure you it is
not fact our bill outlines a robust list
of excluded categories despite this the
document in question includes dozens of
these additional inaccuracies are codes
related to Breaking the nose removing
tumors from the scalp performing lipos
suction and numerous surgeries to remove
tissue from one part of the body place
it on another there are over 30 codes
for lesions larger than the larger the
the eyelid some larger than the entire
face lesions up to 40 in in size we know
this is impossible they know it's
impossible that they portray it as truth
we did attempt negotiations we presented
44 codes off their list asking if any
could go on a post their answer four
codes all of which are extensions of
current statute and do not offer any
compromise or ability to come even
remotely close to current opt School
curriculum we did however receive a 41
page response with pictures that you may
see here
today some of these pictures are for
procedures that are excluded further
some pictures have been left out of the
document
including some surgical procedures that
Doctors of Optometry have performed in
every state in the country including New
Hampshire for decades these procedures
do involve the use of some sharp
instruments on and around the eye
including needles and Opthalmic drills
surgical procedures they likely do not
want you to realize that we routinely
perform safely and
effectively perhaps this list is a
misunder understanding as they did not
go to optometry school and do not have
our training or perhaps the list are
calculated effort to scare the public
and the legislature a tactic that has
been repeated over the past 40 years
when they have AOS every single Bill we
have put forth not surprisingly here we
are again in
2024 them saying the same thing despite
optometry's Decades of exemplary care to
the citizens of New Hampshire Optometry
asks you as the legislature to see
please see through these Scare Tactics
and support Senate Bill 440 Doctors of
Optometry know what Optometry is our
board knows what Optometry is and the
board will regulate our profession
logically methodically and safely for
the citizens of New Hampshire as we have
done successfully for over 113 Years
thank
you thank
you yes represent angle thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question you
mentioned there's 58 codes now that 20
258 but you said that excluded like 200
or something yes and of those 58 what
number number of those can you do right
now in New Hampshire about 20 off of
this procedural code list that they have
presented leaves approximately 40 up for
discussion I ask one more follow and do
you have a list of those for us we we do
have a list that we can provide to you
thank you
yes thank
you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I think
we need to have the these lists papers
and documents and so forth as quickly as
possible so we who are not practitioners
of at least not to my knowledge of
either one of the the Arts that are
under discussion here can kind of check
off and because I think we're going to
have battling documentation so we have
to have uh some way of kind of keeping
score of things that we've been led to
believe are going to happen or not going
to happen or whatever and uh so we can
keep
track that sounds great we can certainly
get that to if we don't have it in there
for you already thank you thank you I
will mention this bill is going to be
going to subcommittee to evaluate the
details representative uh thank you
madam chairman um I'll I'll tell you out
of fun I'm not I have no medical
background uh and um I'm I'm chairman of
the Health and Human Services committee
so I I do get involved with these bills
and at one point we weren't sure if this
bill was coming to our committee prior
to coming to this committee and you
probably followed that whole drama I
don't know yes I did but uh it's been a
been quite a topic of conversation over
the last several weeks um so looking at
the bill and there I'll fully admit this
a lot I don't understand of course yeah
uh but one issue that's been raised by
some of my constituents and others is uh
there's a certain training certain
residen you need to complete to do some
of the procedures that it's my
understanding you're requesting to be
able to do and I was wondering if you
could address that because that's I
think that's one of the sticking points
in this whole this whole situation sure
there are going to be speakers coming on
after me that do address in detail the
education that's required to become an
optometrist and the education that is
involved in some of these procedures
that the board may be looking at um with
um once we gain the authority to do that
um but we do have two experts on
education from the from two current
Optometry programs that can discuss um
maybe in more detail than you'd like to
hear the um uh the uh educational
requirements necessary thank
you just a quick technical Point Madam
chair there are several Representatives
uh joining us today if you if you're
sitting behind a name plate that is not
yours you need to turn it over so you're
not going to be
misidentified thank you that's fair
enough represent goalie just the
question of the chair if this is going
to subcommittee I'm assuming Health and
Human Services committee is going to be
participating in that subcommittee I
will take all the help we can get yes
represented lus and uh which
subcommittee uh I was expecting it to go
to the licensing committee unless some
subcommittee unless someone else
volunteers was that yes we you will you
will get a great deal of help on this
one not that we need it all
right uh Christine
Morse good afternoon madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Christy moris I'm a pediatric
opthalmologist here in conquer and I'm
vice president of the New Hampshire
Society of ey Physicians and
surgeons in New Hampshire
opthalmologists have a long tradition of
collaborating closely with our
Optometric colleagues Who We Believe are
an integral part of larger private
practices for routine eye exams and to
help medically manage eye conditions
such as
glaucoma s SP 440 includes an exclusion
list that dramatically expands optometer
scope of practice potentially granting
New Hampshire optometrist one of the
broadest scope of practice in the US if
this is
enacted the information you heard
earlier regarding access to Eye Care
from opthalmologists is actually
different from our live experience 90%
of patients in New Hampshire live within
a 30 minute drive of an opthomology
ologist a survey of opthalmologist in
our state showed that 94% of
opthalmologists can accommodate surgical
laser patients within a onewe time frame
we do same day procedures and make sure
there is appropriate care afterwards but
it's important to note that these
surgeries we are talking about are
elective non-urgent surgeries we can do
them quickly for patient convenience but
the majority of our patients choose to
schedule them 2 to 4 weeks out testimony
from two states that allow optometrist
to perform laser surgery in Oklahoma and
Kentucky show that there has been no
improved access to care for patients in
those
States the optometrist are specifically
looking to perform 44 surgeries
including eyelid surgery and three laser
surgeries which are performed by
comprehensive opthalmologist a
postcataract surgery laser and two
glaucoma surgeries all usually performed
once in a lifetime you will hear about
these procedures in more depth from my
colleagues today in addition SB 440
would be one of the largest expansions
of Optometric scope of practice in the
continental United States 41 States Plus
Puerto Rico and the District of Colombia
prohibit optometrist from performing eye
surgery since 2011 over a 100 bills have
been introduced in 36 States regarding
Optometric expansion of surgical
privileges in
2023 11 States considered Optometric
legislation none of which passed
including our neighboring state of
Vermont which voted down similar
legislation to S SP 440 and they cited
inadequate training and insufficient
evidence to Su to suggest an access
issue we would be the only such state in
New England if this bill were to pass
the proposed legislation would also
allow for a completely self-regulating
Optometry board unprecedented in the
state of New Hampshire and be the only
such board to exist in the continental
US the medical providers that have
independent boards such as Dentistry
Podiatry and physical therapy operate
under a opes of the opl and require
legislative approval before allowing any
expansion of practice by creating an
exclusion list to Define their scope of
practice the new Optometry board created
through this legislation would have the
sole authority to Grant optometrist
privileges to perform these surgical
procedures and to use any new
technologies that will arise and
determine the standards no matter how
minimal to perform highly complex
surgery s sp44 uses exclusionary
language it would authorize the
Optometry board to have sole authority
to Grant surgical privileges it does not
specify the criteria the board would use
to Grant these privileges states that
have passed similar legislation like
Louisiana and Mississippi require
optometrist to show laser Surgical
coursework and optometry school or have
completed a 32-hour week course both of
which we find inadequate for complex
surgical training given that the board
of Optometry would consist of four
optometrist and only one public member
governing 333 licensed New Hampshire
optometrist we have concerns about
potential bias if a patient complaint
arises from a surgery performed by an
optometrist in
contrast the Board of Medicine includes
11 members chosen from
12,640
licenses the large number of Physicians
and diversity of Physicians practicing
in different Medical Specialties in our
states really reassures patients that
complaints that are brought to the Board
of Medicine can be independently
assessed without an unintended bias it
would be difficult to create a similar
model with so few
optometrist opthalmologists are opposed
to S SP 440 because we are concerned
about patient safety in 2021 an
optometrist in a New Hampshire practice
felt that the existing law on glaucoma
management was too restricted
prohibiting optometrist from prescribing
some treatments imposed unnecessary
restrictions on optometrist seeking
glaucoma
certification collaboratively we worked
in good faith with the New Hampshire
Optometric Society to broaden this law
in contrast SB 440 proposes an optometry
scope of practice expansion for which
they lack sufficient training education
and
experience the bill would also offer
dangerous dangerously broad power to the
Optometry board and would permit
optometrist to perform surgical
procedures and use technologies that
have not even been invented yet all of
this without allowing review and
oversight by the legislature or other
appropriate governing bodies within the
fields of medicine and surgery where
Decades of experience and proper
training assure the safety success and
outcomes that the patients of New
Hampshire expect I respectfully ask that
you oppose s SP 440 thank
you thank
you thank you madam chair so were you
involved with the negotiations of with
the um optometrist on the possible um
agreement ment between these procedures
no but one of our later speakers was
involved so you can explain to us why
you were unwilling to compromise oh no
we did meet with the optometrist and we
willing to compromise but our efforts
were rejected by the
optometrist okay well I'll wait to I'll
I'll wait for that question later thank
you
okay yes I'm afraid I don't he your now
thank you madam chairman um my name is
Jim Murphy I'm one of The Interlopers
from the HHS committee so I'm sorry if I
don't have a name plag in front of me
that's it's okay um my question Dr
Morris is you know could you detail to
us your your training and the number of
potential surgeries that you have done
throughout the not only the course of
your training which I mean was fairly
extensive but also subsequently on live
patients yes and um one of our speakers
has those exact numbers and we'll speak
to that but I can tell you that in
training I performed over 400 cataract
surgeries um equal number of lasers I've
been in practice now here in New
Hampshire for 30 years I do at least six
surgical procedures a week um I mean I
do a lot of surgery and that training
though learning when I was in in
residency was really one-on-one
mentorship um it was on live patients um
after working in wet
Labs just follow up quick followup and
how many years of residency and training
did you have number one and number two
over the past 30 years have you had to
prescribe any hydrocodone to your
patients um I'll take the last question
first no I have never prescribed
hydrocodone and that my feeling is that
if a patient of mine needs hydrocodone I
better see that patient because
something is not right um so and as far
as education after Co after four years
of college four years of medical school
um a year of surgical internship three
years of residency and then a fellowship
in pediatric Opthalmology and adult
strabismus thank you represent laus
thank you um so if I understood
correctly you said the uh the board of
Optometry would be able to you know
change the rules or make up rules
without any oversight of the legis ISL
but un but correct me if I'm wrong but
it looks like uh it says they shall
adopt rules under RSA 541a to carry out
the provisions of the section and to
ensure safety of the public and that
involves among a lot of other things
that process uh reviewed by the
legislature is there something else here
that I'm missing well the board the this
newly created Board of Optometry would
be self-regulating unlike the Board of
Medicine that um has multiple different
medical and Surgical sub specialty
representation the board of Optometry
would include four optometrist and one
public member follow up follow yeah I
understand that but uh I just question
the the you know whether I'm missing
something about the statement that no
overview of the legislature because that
is part of the process unless I'm
missing something here
okay was I I was just wondering if if uh
but but this um that board of optom
would be created through this
legislation understood all right thank
you representative
Pera thank you I believe that M that
representative leus is referring to jail
car because all of room making goes
through the authority of the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules U my question to you is there are
other professions who have their own
boards that govern themselves so what's
the issue with with the optim the
optometrist having having their own
board well the Board of Nursing has
39,18401
27 and Optometry has 333
licenses there are 100 podiatrists
108 yes
thank
you representative Schmidt you have a
brief question thank you madam chairman
so I I you've already announced that
this is going to subcommittee and and I
hoping I'm hoping you'll uh engage
fairly quickly to explain that that we
cannot get into a lot of specifics and
help guide the testimony but my question
is are there any states which have
expanded um eye treatment or I eye
treatment or care uh in this country
that have done it right which we could
you look to to compare with the document
that we are potentially you will be
hearing from another one of my
colleagues to address that okay thank
you all right thank you thank you for
your time Angel leque Sawyer
good afternoon Madam chair
representatives of the committee thank
you for your time um my name is Dr Angel
Le Sawyer I'm originally from nasua I'm
now an optometrist and practice owner uh
in rural Northern parts of our state
having office locations in North Conway
and Berlin where I've practiced for the
last 10 years I am here today to ask for
your support for Senate Bill 440 because
it is what my patients and the citizens
of New Hampshire deserve in order to
better meet their eye care needs before
I get into the rest of my testimony
which I know you have written and I'll
try and shorten as much as possible I
would like to respond to some of the
questions if I may um first I would like
to point out that there are 12 states
that allow laser procedures that means
that there are 38 that do not not 41 um
perhaps they haven't been keeping up
with the states that have already passed
that Authority this year um Vermont did
not pass that Authority however Mt did
have the recommendations and very
specific outlines um of the
recommendations for the off office of
professional relations that did not pass
the other bills that were mentioned in
other states that did not pass were for
political reasons as was mentioned
there's a national campaign labeled stop
scope creep that their only purpose is
to stop advancement from anybody who is
not an MD that is why bills have failed
and why this takes very long time for
this to go through and happen but 12
states have been successful we are
picking up pace just as everything that
has come before us eventually all 50
states have passed that legislation the
legislation to instill dilating drops to
treat with prescription medications to
provide oral medications to treat
glaucoma all of those started one state
at a time and eventually 12 States got
there then 50 states got there all 50
states allow those things I firmly
believe that in my lifetime all 50
states are going to have the ability to
do these procedures because this is the
current curriculum I was taught this in
my schools 15 years ago it has been the
standard in curriculum for years and
will continue to be so I hope that I
don't have to wait another 20 years
before I'm seeing this happen in New
Hampshire and for my
patients um when we did sit down and I
was in the negotiation meeting so I can
answer any questions there when we did
sit down um it was made clear by them
and that was already made clear today
that they believe we're creating a new
board we are not creating a new board of
Optometry as you know there is a board
of Optometry already in place
that consists of four optometrists and a
public member and that has been there
for 113 years as we have heard the only
thing that is new is what we are
permitting that board to do which puts
them on par with other independent
Professional Regulations uh professional
health care providers in the state as we
have mentioned Optometry is being
treated differently than all of the
others and there's no reason for that to
be the case any longer we are not
creating a new board when we sat down
for that negotiation meeting the
opposition asked what is oplc they do
not even know what any of this is they
do not know how we are regulated they
think that we're creating a new board
and that we're going to operate in a
vacuum that is not the case the board
will continue to be the board that it is
it will continue to be subject to the
other regulations of oplc and it will be
bound by the legislature by the statute
that is still in place there is a very
broad range of exclusions that
optometrists will not be able to do that
are outside of the purview of Optometry
that is outside of our metric education
the board cannot subvert those
exclusions there is still precautions
that are in state and that are putting
those parameters in place so for for
that um the the last thing I want to say
in response to what has come before um
the four procedures that were brought
forward were specifically told that
those were being allowed because they
did not consider those procedures to be
surgery the 44 procedures that we were
requesting that are within our training
and education they considered to be
surgery and they made it clear that
there is a line in the sand they will
not allow non-surgeons to do surgery
even though there are nonsurgeons that
are doing surgery in the state they will
not allow non-surgeons to do surgery
that if they're lying in the sand that
comes from the American Medical
Association that comes from the American
Academy of
Opthalmology so there was no room for
negotiation Beyond those four codes
because they consider those surgery and
everything else as far as they're
concerned is off the table are there
other states that have done this
successfully yes there are 12 states
that have but to answer your question
none of them will tell you that they are
doing it successfully because as far as
they're concerned every one of those
States is wrong none of them should be
allowing surgery that is what we're
facing so I I won't go into all of my
testimony here but I will ask you to
please understand this this is an access
issue that is really what my testimony
was meant to focus on I practice in
North Conway and in
um in your uh information we've provided
you a state access map they've said that
90% are within 30 minutes I can tell you
100% of my patients in my Berlin office
are not within 90 within 30 miles within
a 30- minute
drive it is an access issue a 2022
article by the American Academy of
Opthalmology indicated that the number
of opthalmologists in the US has
remained stable since
1990 meanwhile the patients over 60 is
sily
increasing another article published in
September of 2023 by the American
Academy of Opthalmology found that from
2020 to 2035 the total Opthalmology
Supply is uh expected to decrease by 12%
and the total demand is projected to
increase by 24% resulting in a supply
and demand mismatch of only 70%
Workforce adequacy for Opthalmology that
was the second worst among 38 medical
and surgical specialties
and that adequacy that Workforce
inadequacy it plummets to only 29% when
we are looking at Rural and non-metro
geographies it is a real issue I can
tell you that every
day in my 10 years practicing in the
North Country I've seen the only
provider that was the only
opthalmologist in Coos County retired
just closed his
doors in 2015 um that was in 2015 uh
together with the local hospital Andrew
scogan Valley Hospital I was able to
recruit an opthalmologist from Southern
New Hampshire to come up and provide
surgery in Berlin cataract surgeries to
patients eight times in a year however
that that travel became too burdensome
and that was abruptly discontinued in
2021 and we've been unable to find
anybody else willing to travel up there
to provide care to these
patients the hospital has launched a
nationwide search they're unable to find
anybody to come they had one candidate
come in interview for a full-time
Opthalmology position in Berlin and that
person or decline the the
opportunity um since I don't have
Opthalmology in the Coos County area um
for for several years now I've had to
refer patients um a minimum of one hour
from Berlin to get to an Opthomologist
there are two options for a general
opthalmologist within one hour of
Berlin should those opthalmologists not
be able to provide the specialty care
that I need or should they not be on the
insurance panels of my patients that is
a real issue there is one of our Managed
Care Medicaid plans that has one
opthalmologist in the entire State
available for us to refer to there are
other opthalmologists that do not take
the other medic manag Medicare plans
Medicaid plans sorry so when I have
access issues when I have insurance
issues for many years I've had to have
my patients from the North Country
travel two and a half hours to Dartmouth
but at least that used to be an option
because guess what Dartmouth has closed
to referrals I cannot refer a patient to
Dartmouth and have not been able to for
months they've not only closed to
external referrals they at times have
been closed to internal referrals where
op optometrists within Dartmouth cannot
refer to Opthalmology Specialties in
Dartmouth if you look at the map you
will see that there's two counties Coos
and Sullivan that do not have a single
opthalmologist there are two counties
Grafton and Cheshire or sorry two more
counties Carol and belnap that have only
one opthalmologist for the entire County
there are two more counties Gra and
Chesire that are home to Dartmouth
however when Dartmouth starts taking
stops taking referrals and you exclude
those Dartmouth providers we have a
total of four opthalmologists covering
six counties six of the 10 counties in
New Hampshire this is an access issue
now we can't avoid the need for
opthomology there are so many procedures
that are outside the scope of Optometry
that are still Beyond those exclusions
that we need to refer to them I can't
avoid that but we can treat the things
that we're able to treat that are within
the training and education of
optometrists when I was in optometry
school more than 15 years ago I was
trained on these procedures I was able
to do them in Oklahoma where I did my
training I've done these procedures on
patients yet now 15 years later I need
to
refer just a week ago I had a patient
who was in my office had a a skin tag or
a papala on their eyelid that they asked
me to remove for them I told them I have
the training I have the knowledge I have
the experience is doing this in Oklahoma
but I can't do that for you in New
Hampshire oh but I do see that your
nurse practitioner that's your primary
care provider who I also see as as a My
Provider um she can remove that for you
nurse practitioners they can remove skin
tags the patient said to me but you are
my eye doctor I said I know it doesn't
make sense to me
either there are so many reasons to
support s440 it reduces patient cost
travel weight times and increasing
access issues to care
it create it increases continuity of
care it eliminates duplicative health
care
services and also makes the granite
state a more desirable place to live on
the contrary you will hear only one
argument in opposition to S SP 440 which
is a false claim of threat to patient
safety this is a false claim because in
numerous other states and for more than
30 years Doctors of Optometry have been
performing these procedures safely this
is a false claim because the opposition
will say that we do not have their
appropriate Education and Training what
they actually mean is that we do not
have their Education and Training which
is true we know there are significant
differences between the Education and
Training of optometrists and
opthalmologists however that does not
make them the only ones capable of
Performing the procedures um outlined in
s SP 440 we do not want to be
opthalmologists and s440 contains a long
list of exclusions to make that clear we
are simply asking to perform procedures
that were are within our Education and
Training that have been demonstrated to
be safe in many other states and which
are of benefit to our
patients before I close I ask that you
allow me to read a letter from a
wolfboro resident who couldn't be here
today but this is a patient of a dear
Optometric colleague of mine at wolfboro
Eye Associates and a copy of that I
believe is is available to you it
references one of the in office
procedures that we would be permitted by
s440 to perform called a capsulotomy
which removes the cloudy vision limiting
tissue that can develop after cataract
surgery using a yag laser she writes
after a very long and challenging wait
to receive a yag capsulotomy here in New
Hampshire I feel compelled to encourage
legislation to allow the procedure to be
performed by an
optometrist when my vision became cloudy
I made an appointment with the
opthalmologist who performed my cataract
surgery I was scheduled and examined but
I couldn't be seen for the yag treatment
for six weeks this was not waiting on a
referral they saw their surgeon and they
still had to wait six
weeks during this period the condition
grew worse what made this extremely
difficult is that I am a retired
77-year-old who lives alone in a rural
area and has Vision in only one eye I
was unable to drive and became dependent
on others to complete the most basic
errands like grocery shopping Banking
and social activities such as traveling
to visit family I was unable to read or
pass the time with my usual activities
such as writing painting sewing or even
preparing meals and keeping my house
clean I couldn't read emails or texts
although others told me that the
correction of this cloudy condition was
quick painless and instantly effective I
still experienced a prolonged sense of
anxiety considering my eyesight was on
the line eventually made it to the
conquered eye center but I wondered why
I had to EXT endure such a long
frustrating stretch when such an
impressively large facility exists
whatever the reason the proposal to
allow yag capsulotomy to be performed by
local and well-trained optometrists
would certainly alleviate the suffering
of those quality of life uh of those
whose quality of life is diminished by
limited Vision thank you for your
attention and concern Pamela Hansen
wolfboro so I ask you to limit
unnecessary hardships such as this for
the citizens of New Hampshire for my
patience and for your constituents I ask
that you please vote in favor of Senate
Bill 440 thank you for your
time thank you sh
it thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh you alluded to the
number of
opthalmologists likely to decrease going
into the future do you have information
on
the proposed or possible numbers of
optometrists going forward I don't have
that number in front of me but I I it is
increasing there are more optomet
schools that are that are opening um in
the last 15 years I believe that there
have been six or seven new Optometry
schools that are opening and um the
numbers in each class is growing each
year so the numbers of optometrists are
continue to steadily incline to
increase thank you mad thank you madam
chair thank you for saying my
question I look here at a number of
electives that you'll be able to do if
this passes and can you tell me if
all of these that are listed in this
[Music]
legislation are the ones that same ones
that are allowed in the other states
that allow these procedures like
Oklahoma the there are variations um
everything that would be permitted by
s440 in New Hampshire is permitted in
Oklahoma um other states there are
varying degrees there are 12 states that
are permitting um laser procedures um
there's specifically three laser
procedures that um are are of
consequence quence um that that we're
discussing here that we're targeting um
the lid procedures there is a a wider
variation of what those lid procedures
constitute that's where the majority of
um the variation in those those
procedures come up um and so I I can't
say that every state that there there
are more states that allow lid
procedures um there are 12 that allow
lasers there are 19 that allow lid
procedures um and so within those 19
states there may be varying degrees as
to what specific Ally lid procedures are
permitted follow thank you follow up
follow
up
so out of all the states how many states
include this whole list that you have
here in this piece of legislation the
only that I can know for sure as of
right now is Oklahoma but I can get more
specific information for that for you
thank you representative fra yes thank
you madam chair can you please tell me
are there any optometrist schools School
of optim ometry in the united in in New
Hampshire there are none in New
Hampshire there are two in Massachusetts
we have several students that are here
today because this is so important to
them they want to practice in New
Hampshire they want to know that they
can come to New Hampshire and use the
education that they're learning thank
you I beg your pardon representative
Schmidt I always have interesting
questions Madam
chair so uh you've already been informed
that it's it's going to subcommittee so
we're going to have to have people who
are available to come to subcommittee
and you have come a long way today I
can't imagine you can easily come down
on a regular basis but please all of you
can you tell us when you testify whether
you will be available to work with a
subcommittee I will absolutely make
myself available it is that critical to
my patients my patients know how
passionate I am about this um they know
that I'm doing this for their benefit
and they are happy to re schedule their
their exams I fortunately also have
another associate that can help help
hold down the fort and is doing so today
so I will absolutely be available and we
have a strong team that are also willing
to be available whenever you need us I
noticed your passion so thank you for
being
available Smith represent Smith
representative Smith thank you thank you
madam chair um because New Hampshire is
thin we're close to both Maine and
Vermont are there opthalmologists
available to Hampshire residents in
either one of those two states thank you
for asking that um in fact I'm right on
the practicing on the border of Maine my
my number one referral source for all of
my glaucoma patients has been main ey
Center in Portland for years I've sent
them for the glaucoma lasers that I need
treatment for um my patients have about
an hour and 15 minutes to get to
Portland from North Conway um when I
referred last month I was told January
is when my patient would be seen so they
are also experiencing access issues as
well and like Newport or Island followup
pardon me followup followup uh Newport
or Island Pond Vermont do they have any
resources that you could into um on the
Vermont border there is um the one
provider that we do have um up in the uh
Littleton region that's up close to
Berlin that's one of the two options
that I have he practices on both sides
of the state so he is the Vermont option
that I have available I have the
Portland Main opt option available okay
thank you thank
you representative
McDonald thank you madam chairman Wayne
McDonald chairman of Health and Human
Services I think I was in that meeting
you referred to earlier um and and again
I as I as I told the previous individual
I'm I have no medical background and
it's a lot about this belill I don't
pretend to understand um what one thing
that's been brought to my attention and
you know that's what the benefit of
these hearings are so you can hear both
sides and get a better understanding I
won't be voting on this bill in this
committee but as a member of the house I
will be voting for it obviously when it
gets to the
floor uh boards are something that this
the executive department the
administration committee handles and we
deal with public health issues uh there
is a public health issue tangental
related to this board however the the
board of Optometry that you know and the
revisions you'll be making here it's my
understanding you said it's not going to
change really there is a board now but
it's my understanding that this board
will expand in terms of authority and
only Alaska will have a comparable board
in the entire country is that
true the board of New Hampshire would
expand Authority and they will be put on
par with the other independent
practicing doctorate level professions
in the state of New Hampshire that are
regulated in the same way follow up
Madam follow so but but in terms of
other states would would I mean is are
other states comparable or only is
Alaska comparable Alaska has a uh a
statute where their board is able to
regulate um to a greater extent I do not
know of others at this point
um I don't also know cannot speak to
other states and their Podiatry or their
pharmacology or their physical therapy
statutes but I do know what those
statutes are in New
Hampshire okay thank
you thank you very much represent
manrey thank you madam chair as
um thank you for taking my question as a
podiatrist uh board you also regulate
disciplinary actions and in the past 113
years that You' have said uh what is
your average disciplinary questions of
referrals per
year I I can have the board follow up
with that I can tell you that there have
been no disciplinary actions um I do not
know the number of things that are
brought before the board that do not
rise to the level of disciplinary action
but I can tell you that there have been
zero actions T taken I can also tell you
that in every scope practice um that
across the country whether it's the
dilating drops the therapeutic ey drops
the oral medications the treatment of
glaucoma or these surgical procedures
there has never been a reeal or roll
back of the Optometric statute that has
been gone forward we proceed with
caution with safety and with our best
patient best interest in mind thank you
you thank
you thank you thank you Aaron
fogal Madam chair would it be okay if we
invite if I invite Dr Ben Harvey to join
me um to expedite expedite the hearing
thank you Expedition is
good and don't overestimate our
attention spans
Madam chair and representatives of the
committee thank you for hearing me I'm
from Oklahoma I am a board certified
opthalmologist I did my residency in
Opthalmology and fellowship training in
glaucoma and I've been practicing for
about 12 years in adult and pediatric
glaucoma in Oklahoma City I've been
tasked to talk about complications we
see from optometrist performing laser
surgeries since the uh passage of that
scope expansion in Oklahoma many decades
ago these affect my patients personally
my practice and my uh colleagues we all
deal with these complications that we
see from uh referral sources uh due to
these complications I have a patient
with what we call neovascular glaucoma
it's a glaucoma related related to
diabetes who had sudden increase in eye
pressure pain decreased Vision an
optometrist called me asking me to do a
laser he said he was was going to do it
but he didn't have it at this satellite
location I agreed to see the patient
bring the patient in and the patient was
misdiagnosed he had acute he did not
have what the optometrist said he had
the optometrist thought he had acute
angle closure when in fact he did have
the diabetes related glaucoma this
glaucoma if that laser was performed for
acute angle closure would have worsened
the disease and led to a bad outcome so
that's just a a prequel for me speaking
about the essential necessity for
patient safety we are dealing with uh
complications from these procedures
you'll hear from a patient of mine later
on today not only are these lasers
potentially dangerous and we do see
complications of them in Oklahoma but we
also see improper diagnosis of diseases
and utilization of wrong lasers for
wrong diseases frequently in
Oklahoma there is a patient of mine I
recently diagnosed with GL
she had been going to the optometry
school in North Oklahoma they had not
diagnosed nor had they treated her gloma
but they had been doing multiple lasers
in her eyes to treat her floaters these
lasers side effects include pressure
spikes in her eyes pressure spikes in a
patient with glaucoma leads to nerve
death nerve death is irreversible leads
to
blindness we have a patient who was seen
for months for a painful red eye by two
different optometrists who were
surgically trained uh the patient was
eventually sent to the emergency room
the emergency room doctor not the
optometrist uh diagnosed the patient
with acute angle closure and sent the
patient to an opthalmologist for laser
surgery unfortunately due to delay in
diagnosis and treatment the patient
could not have this laser surgery had to
go to the operating room a lawsuit
ensued it did not materialize because
the patient passed away before it could
go through the proper
channels we have patients in the
community who are veterans but treated
by community opthalmologist and
optometrist this particular patient went
to an optometrist and had laser in both
eyes for what we call narrow angles
treating a angle closure glaucoma the
lasers were not successful were not
completed because in one eye the eye
started bleeding filled up with blood
the the optometrist proceeded to do the
laser in the other eye unable to
complete the eye filled up with blood
the pressures elevated marketly this was
treated conservatively by The
opthalmologist Who finally got the
patient and when they did uh evaluate
the patient once the blood was gone and
they could see all the structures in
fact this patient did not need that
laser this patient had open angles not
closed angles that were the reasoning
behind this laser done by the
optometrist we've had patient go to one
of our cornea Specialists seeking lasic
wanted to do lasic on both eyes to
improve their vision and and perhaps get
independence from spectacles the cornea
specialist and opthalmologist who does
another year of training to deal
specifically with the cornea see that
that this patient is not a candidate for
lasic surgery it would be detrimental to
the patient to do this surgery the
patient
uh was uh really motivated so got a
second opinion from an optometrist who
said you know currently we can't do the
the procedure but I'll see if we can do
it in the future two weeks later
patient's contacted by the optometrist
lasic is performed patient had worse
Vision in the outcome compared to before
the surgery went back to the cornea
specialist couldn't fix it there's no
way to fix that you'll be hearing a lot
about lasers after cataract surgery
we'll call them yag capsulotomies or we
can call them yag lasers so we don't get
too technical we see patients who have
this laser done by optometrist when it
was actually uncorrected a stigmatism
causing the visual Distortion a simple
glasses refraction would have fixed this
rather than a laser we've had this laser
performed when it was macular
degeneration causing the vision decrease
rather than a uh problem after cataract
surgery requiring this laser done by
optometrist we've had this surgery done
in patients who've already had this the
laser done by
optometrist um all these would have been
avoided if proper slit L examination and
patient physical history were perfected
in this scenario to do surgery okay
again this is about patient
safety it's about ensuring that they get
the best care and the highest quality
Care possible I thank you for allowing
me to speak uh I have a question how do
you uh excuse how do you
bring reconcile that those comments with
the report that there are have not been
very many uh disciplinary issues in
Oklahoma is that incorrect or did I
misunderstand no there haven't been very
disciplinary very many disciplinary
actions why the board has not taken care
of these does it not ever reach the
board or does the board know about it
and not do anything I couldn't tell you
that did you did you report the cases
that came to your attention to the board
the ca one of the cases practice one of
the cases has already been presented and
there was a lawsuit and you'll hear
about that later some of the other cases
were from my colleagues some of the
cases
had necessarily a improper uh procedure
done for example doing a open angle
glaucoma procedure on an angle closure
patient and vice
versa doing reporting that to the board
I've reported things to the board in the
past and had no traction so that's
something I don't do regularly thank
you repres represent
Murphy thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question it
sounds as though you have a referral
practice of the of sorts with multiple
subsp Specialists what percentage of
your uh referrals in that are
complications do you think come from
optometrist versus optomologist
referrals from opthalmologist versus
optometrist it's it's not a large
portion of my practice of either one so
I I would say a very small percentage of
my total practice are patients refer
from complications from opthamologists
or
optometrists thank you representative
gold thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question you gave us um
examples of complications and problems
from surgery from um
optometrist do you have the number of
the similar uh complications from AOL
I'm going to say that wrong from your
profession in the same time period in
Oklahoma you know I do not that that can
be made available and it's made
available because we have an independent
uh Medical Board that oversees that and
P and these Physicians also have uh uh
local state Medical Association not of
opthalmologists that oversees that as
well thank you that number would be
helpful if you could get that for us to
compare
Mone say your name again please my name
is Aon Fogle thank you to the members of
the committee and Madam chair for
allowing us to give our testimony this
afternoon before I do that I would like
to address representative leus and um
representative McDonald's question about
board authority if you have a copy of
the um SB 440 in front of you I would
ask you to look at page seven line
two this is a new section in RSA
3276 DD which reads unless otherwise
specified in this chapter the board
shall have the authority to determine
what constitutes the practice of
Optometry by persons licensed under this
chapter and shall establish the
credentialing requirements which shall
be fulfilled before a person may be
certified to perform optomic procedures
for the practice of Optometry that
language completely eliminates any
future legislative oversight of
Optometry delegating Your Role to the
new
board that new section is contrary to
normal process to not give agencies and
Boards the ability to to make their own
oversight laws and to that end the
notion of a new board having authority
over surgical procedures in New
Hampshire is very likely in direct
conflict with RSA
3291 under the New Hampshire Board of
Medicine
statutes I do also want to address some
other things after my testimony but I
would like to start by introducing
myself a little more thoroughly my name
is Aaron Fogle I'm an opthalmologist
specializing in cornea and cataract
surgery and I'm president of conquered
Eye Center I've practiced in conquered
for 30 years I'm here to speak in
opposition of Senate Bill
440 so when I meet people outside of
work uh and they ask me what I do I
generally say I'm an eye surgeon because
most people don't know the difference in
the skill set or training between an
opthalmologist and an
optometrist and since we're here to talk
about an eye surgery bill I want to tell
you what goes was into becoming an eye
surgeon and how that differs from the
training of an
optometrist following College an
opthalmologist spends four years in
medical school learning anatomy and
physiology and the diseases that plague
us in our third and fourth year we start
doing uh procedures on patients like
learning how to suit your skin uh I
putting in IVs chest tubes NG tubes and
Central lines and it's not because we
need these specific skills to become ni
surgeon it's that For the First Time We
Touch real live patients they in turn
bleed and vomit move shake and faint we
learn that's what people do surgical
training part
one after graduating as real doctors we
spent a year as interns in a teaching
hospital with critically ill patients
that we are charged with keeping alive
we speak to them about their medical and
surgical treatments the risks benefits
and Alternatives and counsel them when
they've run out of options surgical
training part two our three-year
Residency program in Opthalmology is the
most formal and intense period of
training we're heavily supervised tested
and pushed to absorb the knowledge
necessary to diagnose and treat complex
eye
disease we build our surgical skills not
just by listening to lectures or
practicing in the lab but by
additionally watching our senior
residents and and attending physicians
we begin to do parts of surgical cases
adding steps as we gain skills until
we're deemed competent Enough by our
attending phys physicians to do the
entire case as the primary surgeon we
then Mentor younger surgeons teaching
them what we've learned because nothing
solidifies your knowledge like
teaching we meet patients in our clinics
gaining their trust until they consider
us their eye doctor and if needed we
prepare them for surgery celebrate our
successes with them and learn how to
handle and talk to them about our
complications this is surgical training
part three for our programs to maintain
accreditation we must graduate with a
minimum minimum number of cases
performed as the primary surgeon in a
variety of areas at this point we spent
8 to 10 years in post col training and
more than 177,000 clinical hours this is
what goes into making an eye
surgeon in contrast an optometrist
spends four years in optometry school
learning how to measure and fit glasses
and contact lenses they learn to screen
for and diagnose eye problems they have
lectures in surgical procedures but
there are no opportunities for Hands-On
surgical training with live patients as
nearly every optometry school in this
country is located in a state that does
not give them surgical
privileges in their course curriculum
during optometry school less than 5% of
their credit hours are devoted to laser
and surgery
in their supplementary weekend course
only eight hours are devoted to Hands-On
teaching of eight different procedures
that's one hour per procedure on plastic
eyes that don't move shake or faint and
they don't have minimum standards or
number of cases to become
certified if you'd like I'd invite you
to turn to page eight in your white
booklet there you will see a picture of
a photograph of an optometry student
practicing suturing techniques on a
chicken
breast while this may be a starting
point to learn how to hold the
instruments and tie a suture it can't be
the beginning middle and end of training
for suturing the eyelids or skin around
the eye but it is if you never train on
live patients first of all you don't
have to anesthetize a chicken breast
chicken breasts don't bleed so there's
no opportunity to practice cautery
skills a powerful tool that can melt
tissue and cause permanent aery to
anything it touches if it's not used
properly there are no eyebrows nose or
cheeks to get in the way of suturing a
chicken breast so there's no real life
experience developing ham postures
needed to Su suture in the small tight
space around the eye the chicken breast
isn't going to move blink or ask if
you're done yet finally I doubt anyone's
hand is going to shake when they
approach a chicken breast with a suture
but the first time you do this on a live
patient your hands will definitely shake
and you want a mentor sitting next to
you you don't want to be doing this in
your office by
yourself the second picture you see
there is a plastic eye mounted in front
of a laser some picture some patients
ask if we take out the eyeball and do
surgery on it and then replace it back
all while they're
asleep as ridiculous at that as that
sounds it would make it easier just like
lasering a plastic eyeball no movement
blinking or pulling away to contend with
plastic eyes have no variability in the
way the laser react in the way the
plastic reacts to the
laser there's no need to change laser
settings and no opacity cloudiness or
atypical Anatomy to Cloud The
View we have heard optometrists say they
want to practice to the highest level of
their training but in my opinion most of
them have been given false expectations
by their training programs who say this
training this this training on chicken
breasts and plastic eyeballs is good
enough it simply is not optometrist call
themselves primary eye care doctors not
eye surgeons for good reason because
they aren't but the average New
Hampshire citizen hasn't heard the
lengthy description you've just heard
they don't know the difference between
the two Specialties they depend on the
legislature to license appropriately so
they are guaranteed competency when it
comes to who performs their eye surgery
Senate Bill 440 proposes to bypass the
training needed to perform safe
effective eye
surgery if you'd like I would uh like to
address a term that's been brought up in
response to our um abil our our um our
attempt to compromise I was in the
hearing with um three of my Optometric
colleagues
and um the speaker of the house and we
were able to listen to their requests
and we stand ready to compromise on
several items I think Dr Morris included
in her presentation including allowing
the Odes to prescribe hydrocodone
reducing as they requested the CME
requirement to 20 hours per year
maintaining a self-regulating board and
four procedures on their list that would
expand their current scope by
36% but the term Line in the Sand has
gained momentum in our
discussions we would like to continue
working with our optimetric colleagues
to deliver high quality of care to our
patients we're not trying to be
obstructionists we care about patient
safety but we Define these privileges
that they are requesting as surgery and
we believe only doctors with surgical
training should do
surgery thank you
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
for taking the question and I understand
specifically that this is about patient
safety access is important but
access increasing access doesn't
necessarily increase patient safety so
my question is would you be able to
provide this committee bless you with
those topics that you discussed willing
to compromise on so that we can look at
them because I agree with you 100% that
when you get into surgery and especially
surgery around the eyes correct
diagnosis and making sure you have a
competent person doing that procedure is
important so I would like to have if you
could get us that information um correct
me if I'm wrong Dr KY but I believe
that's all in the blue book that you
have the blue um informational materials
oh yes it probably is
if we can't find it we'll get back to
it ah yes who if whoever was giving out
these handouts could make sure
representative Schmidt has a set we
would appreciate it thank
you
okay thank you very much for your
testimony Cliff CLE
yes oh okay well
then good we'll save them for somebody
who else who needs them thank you
though thanks for finding me thank
you thank you madam chair and the
members of the committee for allowing me
to uh participate in this
hearing um and greetings from the
Commonwealth of Kent
I apologize if my accent is a problem uh
with the proceedings today perhaps the
translator would have been in order um
my name is Cliff CLE I'm a practicing
optometrist in the state of Kentucky I
graduated in 1995 I did a residency in
Primary Care Optometry at
Oklahoma um several years after they
received privileges to do these
procedures and had been performing them
on my fellow kentuckians um on and off
for roughly that time since
2015 uh I joined the Kentucky College of
Optometry which is a new College of
Optometry located in rural Eastern
Kentucky and one of the reasons why I
joined there was
because our scope of practice included
these procedures for our fellow
kentuckians and I wanted to be a part of
the training team that was responsible
for making sure that my future
colleagues would be competent in these
procedures so I want to make sure that
the committee understands that a lot of
the
foundational uh training that students
receive in optometry school is in the
areas of anatomy physiology pharmacology
pathology okay and Optics and and other
refractive issues those are the
foundational things that any surgeon
needs any uh healthc care provider needs
and those things have been in optimetric
education long before uh I became into
this or came into this profession in the
last probably 20 years or so the schools
have started to add some of the
curriculum necessary to be specific to
Opthalmic procedures that we're
discussing
today these laser procedures especially
are procedures that utilize what's known
as a slit lamp which which is attached
or or added to the laser uh components
are and these students start using a
slit lamp in their first year so they
are learning how to examine how to focus
how to um concentrate the energy the
light the whatever on the specific part
of the eye that they need to early early
in their career a little bit later in
their career then we inform them and
guide them on the specifics necessary to
be able to do that for laser
procedures So currently I am the course
director for two courses at the Kentucky
College of Optometry one of them is
Opthalmic surgery one that's lasers and
Opthalmic surgery 2 that's injections
and periocular procedures okay so what
we do in those courses is build upon the
foundational knowledge of anatomy etc
etc right to make the curriculum
specific for procedural care so yes we
have dactic um uh or lecture uh
classroom uh activities that are
involved in the diagnosis the the um
decision to perform the
procedure um the correct management of
of
complications uh Etc and then we have an
extensive Hands-On Laboratory work that
we do in order for the student to be
provided with the foundational skills
necessary to be able to again focus on
the correct uh tissue to understand the
laser settings and uh understand
informed consent and the process uh of a
surgical procedure for that
day additionally in my state um I also
supervise what's known as the expanded
Therapeutics clinic in which we perform
these procedures routinely L at the
Kentucky College of Optometry and I want
to step back just for a second and and
address one thing that I heard as a
representative of of Kentucky I'd like
to go back a little bit to the access
issue it was mentioned that there was no
reports or little reports of access
problems in Kentucky in Pike County
where I um where I practice if you know
what Kentucky looks like it's that
little point on the very Eastern part
all right um there's not much around
there and currently the wait time for uh
someone to see an opthalmologist for a
procedure like we're discussing today is
6 to n months all right now the patient
can travel two to three hours to have
this done yes but that's part of the
axis that we're talking about here so in
my state one of the reasons why this
institution was developed and placed
there was specifically because of the
access our our bill was known as the
better access to iare act right in
Kentucky we passed that in 2011 and the
school was uh graduated its first class
in 2020 entered its first class in 2016
again specifically in response to the
access issue so we dropped the school
right in the middle of where the access
was a problem all right and just like
our osteopathic colleagues at our at our
College we were making a big difference
in serving the underserved in Eastern
Kentucky so I'd like to provide
testimony about the AC ESS in our state
there was also another question about
board autonomy or board um
self-regulation Kentucky is exactly that
there was a question I I apologize from
from this side over here about was there
another state where a board had similar
Authority and Kentucky has that
Authority the Kentucky Board of
Optometry has the authority I believe
exactly what Verbatim what is written in
this one in terms of uh it's the body
that governs the practice of cometry I
can't speak to all of them in the
country but I can tell you that there is
there is Kentucky right and that's been
since
2011 so in addition to the didactic work
that we do we do these procedures in
clinic um at least weekly uh the clinic
that I supervise and they also do it at
a regional hospital which is uh
virtually across the street uh where the
single practicing opthalmologist in Pike
County um is employed so the procedures
are performed at the hospital as well as
well as in our oncampus clinic right and
the process that we go through is the
old Mantra of see one do one teach one
right so our students often come into my
clinic and they watch me do one of these
procedures okay the next one then I am
right there with them like an angel on
their shoulder watching them punch that
button for the first time to do these
laser procedures or do an injection
and I will say with certainty because
I'm the one who does it that these folks
do it correctly they do it safely and
they do it under my ospice all right if
they're not then they're they they're
they're asked in a way as to not alarm a
patient and we say well let me let me
take over for that for you for just a
second or let me take a look for a
second but I'm the one responsible for
providing the care to those to those
patients but I'm also responsible for
providing the care necessary to be able
to train these students to do it and I
take it very very seriously and so do my
colleagues in the other schools and I
want you to understand that this is not
from our standpoint this is not a
political issue we are training these
students to do these procedures in
preparation to get them to go out and
provide the care and provide care in
areas where they need this access right
getting in the way of this is is going
to slow down the ability for optometrist
to be able to do this in the state of
New Hampshire just like it did in the
state of Kentucky I don't think there's
any um any coincidence to the fact that
though there are more schools that have
opened all right in the last few years
and they include this type of curriculum
right because this is becoming the norm
for optometry in other states and New
Hampshire in my opinion should uh get on
board in terms of of understanding that
other states have been doing this often
times for years and years and years and
years uh with an excellent uh safety
track record you have documentation in
there uh some of the specifics about the
curriculum in the schools you have my
testimony um about some of the
curriculum in the schools um you have
you have documents in there about the uh
number of procedures that have per been
performed in several States in Kentucky
the estimate is about 60,000 all right
which with no uh Adverse Events uh
reported to the board right surgery
results in Adverse Events and
complications irrespective of who
performs it right but Adverse Events and
complications are not an admonishment of
incompetency right and I think that's
important to understand so are my
students trained to be able to handle
the complications as well as the
interoperative or the procedural things
yes they are and I think that's one
reason why I wanted to to visit uh
conquered did I did I say it right okay
all right out of here it's Concord sorry
so Concord and uh and and and and bring
this information to you um I'll wrap up
because again you've got you've got my
written testimony in here but um there
are a couple of different standards that
are now starting to be adopted uh
nationally by the Association of schools
and colleges of Optometry which is
obviously the assoc assciation um that
um governs schools and colleges of
Optometry and makes recommendations
about curricula and in a recent outline
a detail outline of the three pillars
excuse me the three pillars of core
competency and surgery that was
professional value and ethics knowledge
and skill and that first one is the one
that I would really like to to to focus
on that professional values and ethics
our colleagues our Optometric colleagues
are not going to perform these
procedures if they have not uh received
enough training for them to be
comfortable to perform these by
licensure our medical colleagues you
know can do virtually any procedure but
you know a uh primary care physician for
example is not going to undergo a
Neurosurgical procedure in a hospital
right because he she has not received
the appropriate training to do that
although by lure he she can do that
right and our colleagues are going to be
very similar if they don't have an
interest in this if they don't have a
Acumen for it or whatever our colleagues
are not going to do that and our board
is going to ensure that that happens so
I I want to try to give you some some um
some Solace here that this is going to
be uh this is going to be handled
professionally and that uh our
colleagues are are certainly have the
same uh professional values and ethics
that uh healthc care providers uh have
across this country and lastly the
accredit ation body that uh accredits
all of our schools and colleges through
the US Department of Education is uh
coming up with uh some standards that
will include these types of procedures
as well so the schools will be um will
be it will be incumbent upon the schools
to make sure that this type of
curriculum is involved um moving forward
you know some of the older schools
that's uh you know something that they
have to you know uh change a little bit
more than some of the newer schools but
now all of this uh as a profession and
as a group of schools and colleges we
have a commitment to be able to provide
this type of
training and I thank you for your time
thank you representative groda thank you
madam chair thank you Dr CLE sure can
you please tell me how many um students
do you have graduating every year from
your in from your school we matriculate
about 60 and our graduating class is
anywhere from 58 to 6 three just
depending on how successful they are in
the in the program followup follow up
and how many years is the program it's
four years last question follow um of
these procedures that are in House
Senate Bill
440 which how many of those procedures
are taught in your school how many of
the procedures are taught all of them
all of them okay all three of the laser
procedures and the lid procedures thank
you representative Schmidt and then gold
thank you madam chair so ordinarily I
would save this question for the
subcommittee but you may not be back
because I I've actually been to Kentucky
if you can believe it believe it I know
Louisville quite well um so so the the
the thing that was brought to our
attention about suture training sure is
this is this it as far as suture
training is concerned or is this perhaps
stage one or whatever that is definitely
stage one and how many other stages of
well in in our institution you know we
we don't we don't use chicken all right
um that's that's just that's just not
what we use in our institution okay um
we tend to use um some animal models but
we use uh we use synthetic you know
models to be able to do it right and
they are more shaped like an eyelid or
an eyebrow or something like that to
give students some of that dexterity
that they need to be able to do that
but yes the stages are essentially you
know models um you know I'm not going to
provide you not factual information
right but the next step to that is that
when they become fourth years in and in
their Clinic with me and we remove a
lesion that requires a suture right then
they perform that along with
me and the other picture about the
eyeball the synthe that that's also just
initial stage it it is accurate and is
an initial stage yes thank you
M yes
please thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question course
um the I I am looking up that uh one of
the university colleges of Optometry has
an ocular surgery
Fellowship um where they get an
opportunity to do a lot of procedures
you know in a training uh mentored uh
Apprentice uh setting is that something
that is common or is that unusual and
and and and would that be maybe an
Avenue for um
making this this this expanded scope
acceptable to everyone right no thank
you for the question uh it is not common
um and it is not common yet because the
need is not out there yet because of the
reduced number of practices or excuse me
the states that have that scope of
practice so a year of specifically in
these procedures that they already have
so much foundational information on I
don't believe is a requirement to be
able to competently and safely do
these gold thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question of
course uh the two first two points I had
you've covered which is that
um that the scope of teaching the using
of the models is a very early stage
that's not the entire scope of training
in your facility right and the second I
think just got covered and that was that
different schools have different levels
of um just like I'm a social worker
trained social worker I can go to one
college and become a great social worker
other colleges not so much sounds like
the same would be true in this field but
my last question that hasn't been yet
covered how has has it gone since 2011
have you seen a lot of malpractice suits
are the boards having to cover a lot of
problems in Kentucky right thank you for
the question um there is a there is a
letter I believe in your packet from the
board uh outlining the number of
procedures and the uh lack of any
disciplinary disciplinary action or
increase in malpractice rates um I can't
specifically provide you that but it
could be provided from the state board
um if that would help in the
subcommittee um uh discussions but I
believe there is one uh letter in there
talking about the number of procedures
and the the lack of disciplinary action
but if further uh you know action is or
or further information is required I'm
sure that the uh state board would be uh
be helpful with that thank
you representative
goalie thank you madam chair thank you
for thanking my
question I had asked before a question
as to how many other states have the
same language as we have in this bill
here was told only
Oklahoma and in your test you asked for
us to get on board the other states out
there and going forward right and is it
my understanding that the only state
going forward with this is Oklahoma and
if it is can you at least tell us what
the difference is what Kentucky has
compared to what this is before yeah I I
don't believe that that statement is
accurate that that's the only well the
only law that's like that our law is
almost verbatim What Oklahoma's is as is
Louisiana's right um so I can speak to
those because I have knowledge of those
um but um they're not the only ones they
were for a long time right um but after
Kentucky went in 2011 Louisiana was very
soon after that right and other states
started uh seeing the wisdom of the
addition of these procedures and those
laws those regulations are extremely
similar to kuy
briefly in follow up on this question is
sure in your estimation how many states
would include all of these procedures
that are here in this piece of
legislation uh of the 12 states that um
allow laser procedures I would say 80%
of them um allow all three of them and
there are a couple that restrict them to
one or two
procedures thank you madam chairman
thanks for taking my question I have a
question in the training process is
there any point when the training wheels
come off and and your student is the
primary surgeon before they graduate yes
sir um so generally what happens is as I
mentioned before I would do a procedure
the student then does a procedure um or
or starts a procedure or maybe finishes
mine you know uh after I have started it
and so that I can I can get an
understanding of how they're performing
and then the next one if you know if I
feel like they're ready and that may
take one or two of those but the next
one then they do the procedure from
start to
finish follow how many would they do it
varies uh it really does vary because it
depends on whether not they do the on
campus rotation with me if they do them
in other uh locations they they may have
different numbers uh than we have there
can you give me like an approximate
number uh no because I don't think that
that would be I don't think it would be
factual to give you a number that every
student
receives there's an assignment could you
give a minimum at least no sir no okay
we don't have we don't have we don't
have a minimum number okay thank
you okay Ros Brown uh thank you madam
chair real quickly as everyone comes up
if you do happen to have something in
one of these documents could you
reference that before you start speaking
so we could hunt it down thank
you all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you Andrew
Kim good afternoon and thank you for
taking the time to hear my testimony my
my name is Dr Andrew Kim and I'm a board
certified dermatologist with dartm
Dartmouth Hitchcock I'm also a clinical
assistant professor of Dermatology with
the Gil school of medicine and I'm also
the president of the New Hampshire
Society of Dermatology I'm in my seventh
year of practice as a dermatologist here
in
conquered many of you may be wondering
why is a dermatologist here talking
about SB 440 and I'm here as a concerned
physician who relies heavily on the
expertise of my Opthalmology colleagues
on a regular basis as a dermatologist I
routinely refer my patients to
opthalmologists for second opinions as
well as co-management of ocular
conditions many of which require surgery
in or around the eyes even as an expert
of the skin who has had extensive
training on surgery in or around the
eyes and the eyelid itself I require the
expert knowledge of my Opthalmology
colleagues to help make tough clinical
decisions as well as carry out surgical
treatments on my patients when I refer
my patients to an eye specialist I
expect nothing less than medical expert
in the diseases in and around the eyes
when a patient sees their eye doctor for
a skin lesion removal I want their
clinician to know that is not a skin tag
but rather a Pinkus tumor which is a
form of Basil cell skin cancer that's a
real world example of one of my patients
who had an optomet perform out of state
this kind of a removal calling it a skin
tag this led to a delay in diagnosis
tumor growth and a much more riskier and
complex reconstruction than what would
have been initially necessary
patients may not and often do not make
the distinction between an
opthalmologist and an optometrist about
10 to 15% of the time I recommend my
patients follow up with an
opthalmologist for further care I find
out after the fact that they they have
seen an abdist instead they do not know
that a doctor of Optometry who
rightfully calls themselves doctor is
not a physician who has gone to medical
school and the subsequent rigorous
residency training I have personally
seen harms from lapses and care due to
fundamental knowledge gaps between these
two very distinct but complimentary
professions with so many of our patients
none the wiser I fear that patients will
unknown only allow someone with less
training and expertise to operate on
such a vital part of their body should
such legislation come to pass an
argument has been made that optometrist
can perform certain procedures and that
they have the training to perform
certain procedures but that doesn't mean
they should perform certain Pro
procedures um just because you know how
to drive a car car and went through
driver's head doesn't make you skill to
drive on black ice in the middle of a
blizzard or the wisdom to know that that
is a bad
idea I have had training in blop
plasties which is surgical eyelid lifts
um in medical conditions and I've had
only about six of these procedures in my
residency
training it overlaps a lot with the type
of training and surgical procedures that
I do in routine Surgical excisions and
suering that being said while 95% of my
outcomes would probably be a good be
good in the 5% of the chances that we
have a negative outcome I know that I am
ill equipped to manage and deal with
these complications when I know I have
far more expert surgical colleagues who
can deal with this and that's why I
don't do that in my practice even though
that was part of my
training many arguments have made in the
sake of expanding scope of practice one
has been access to care in my seven
years of practice here in Conquer New
Hampshire I have personally not
experienced significant access issues
with Opthalmology having referred
hundreds of patients to them while I
have seen wait times uh and in cases
where it has been excessive in my
opinion calling those offices and
speaking to the opthalmologist has
resulted in Faster access for my most
critical patients I believe that this
proposed legislation is a clear danger
to our patients and which is why I've
taken the time out of the busy in middle
of my busy Clinic day to be here today
and ask that this piece of legislation
be
opposed I would also like to add that I
would also not want to confuse access of
care with quality of care the same way
that uh you wouldn't choose to have the
first available person redo a renovation
of your house you wait for the right
person with the right skill set to do so
I believe our patients deserve no less
thank
you sorry any
questions that's okay I think you you
covered it pretty
clearly Alison Lauren
hello Madam chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak to you today I am Dr Allison
the ranger born and raised in Bedford I
graduated from UNH and then attended the
New Hampshire I'm sorry the New England
College of Optometry in Boston I live in
gtown and practice in Manchester at New
Hampshire ey Associates I'm here today
to ask for your support of Senate Bill
440 a bill to modernize the regulation
and the practice of Optometry in New
Hampshire like other doctoral Level
Health Care providers in New Hampshire
doctors of photometry practice
independently we prescribe topical and
oral medications order labs and imaging
perform minor surgical procedures
diagnose and treat ocular diseases and
emergencies we take after hours call and
dictate the treatment and management of
our
patients in these after hour calls calls
in in the emergency appointments that we
see either in our daily clinic or after
hours we manage the complications of
these procedures already we are trained
for that in optometry school and we
practice that in our clinics while there
is overlap between the professions of
Optometry and Opthalmology we remain
independent of each other and each
profession has its own regulatory
board it is inappropriate for another
profession to attempt to dictate which
parts of our skill set we can and cannot
use but unlike other independent doctor
Level Health Care professions in New
Hampshire only Optometry does not have
board autonomy and is required to pass
legislation and to overcome opposition
from a separate profession to be
permitted to use our education and
training which is why our opposition
wants a lot in the statute so they can
maintain their Monopoly on us in their
control over our
profession Senate Bill 440 is not
Progressive or not legislation
optometrists have been performing the
procedures permitted in this bill in
dozens of states and for more than 40
years with safe and effective outcomes
as you've heard 12 states have laser
Authority 19 allow removal of eyelid
lesions and 42 have injectable Authority
Senate bill would allow only minor
in-office surgical procedures that have
long been a part of the curricul
Optometry schools which none are
complexe surgeries performed in a
hospital or ambulatory setting or under
general anesthesia the the board of
Optometry must ensure that the
appropriate regulations and
certifications are in place for Le each
licensed optometrist and that is done
through
rulemaking the fear-mongering only
serves to allow organized medicine to
control markets and prevent competition
which ultimately drives health care
costs up and restricts access the
procedures authorized by Senate Bill 440
have been performed hundreds of
thousands of times by Doctors of
Optometry and other states some since
the
1980s this rhetoric from the opposition
aims to continue to restrict qualif eye
doctors from providing care to New
Hampshire citizens in a climate of
growing provider shortages and access
issues organized medicine continues to
undercut belittle and disparage our
education and that of other non-md
health professionals medical school is
not the sole institution where in office
surgical procedures are taught or where
individuals can receive a legitimate
Healthcare education in-office surgical
procedures are within the scope of
practice of many non-md professions
including Dentistry Podiatry and optom
country in fact Healthcare Providers
without a doctorate degree and a minimal
opic education are authorized to perform
some of the optomic procedures allowed
in Senate Bill 440 yet Doctors of
Optometry in New Hampshire
cannot iare access issues in this state
are undeniable we live with them every
day as eye doctors and as patients and
how does it make sense for a doctor of
Optometry who performed the procedures
authorized by Senate Bill 440 in another
state who then moved to New Hampshire
should be prohibited from performing
these same procedures here I recently
saw a 104-year-old patient whose Vision
was decreased from the haze that
commonly developed after cataract
surgery if I were still practicing in
Colorado where I was for eight years I
could have treated her that day within
minutes however simply because I crossed
a state border and returned home to New
Hampshire I somehow became less educated
and less qualified this patient and
their family had to be inconvenienced
had to schedule an additional
appointment and had to see another
provider that was in the very same
practice the result was the increased
cost to the patient the caretaker and
ultimately increased cost to the Health
Care
System All Eye Care Providers have a
common purpose of providing safe Eye
Care to the citizens of New Hampshire
and for the right reasons with outcomes
and access in mind safe quality ey care
including in offers procedures is not
exclusive to Opthalmology it is time to
work together and allow the optimal use
of all healthc care providers to address
the needs of our patients
and I'd like to say a
couple more things
about the scare scary pictures you'll
see and the scare tactics because we all
see complications from every provider
that a patient sees no one is impervious
to complications it happens we're not
robots and we're not perfect nobody is
and we also see complications in poor
outcomes from opthalmologists but we
don't come here and air it out to you
but every practitioner experien these
these things we wish we were robots that
would be great but it's not our
reality um I
personally have seen many cases from
Opthalmology with misdiagnoses and harm
caused to patients so no one's
impervious and that's what the board is
for and that's what the board currently
does and will continue to do to regulate
our profession um speaking of the board
the medical board Podiatry board
Dentistry board they all have board
autonomy and as you know are under the
umbrella of the oplc and
there are attorneys and people that that
watch the boards and make sure that they
behave so um and do things that they
should be doing so um we are the only
ones that are restricted in statute and
cannot Advance with Health Care advances
and in our profession and no profession
should stand still that does not help
anybody um as far as you know yesterday
I had a patient faint on me and clinic
and I have lots of patients that move
around and squirm and they are very
nervous and I and I empathize with them
I would be too if I had someone removing
a big piece of metal from my eye um or
trying to to clean up their large cornal
abrasion that they have um so we are
trained and and we see patients that
move a lot as well on a daily basis and
we're seeing them in a microscope and
this is the same microscope that is used
um with the laser so we are thoroughly I
see 25 patients a day on this
microscope thank you for hearing me
today I have one question you keep
talking about procedures authorized by
Senate Bill 440 when I look at it all I
can see is a list of things that are not
allowed where does it specify what is
allowed well that would be for the board
to decide like the other boards do for
dentistry and Podiatry and for medicine
well then you shouldn't say that they
are authorized by Senate Bill 440
because that's
incorrect they wouldn't be excluded by
Senate Bill 440 thank you
sure all right thank you for your
testimony
sir Vicky rutage
Madam chair committee thank you for
allowing me to share my story my name is
Vicki rage I am a CH tribal member from
Southeastern Oklahoma um in 2018 I saw
my private optometrist who performed
routine Health Care such as uh
contacts glasses annual visits two years
previously he had referred me to RPG in
Sherman Texas because I had a cataract
on my right eye and at that time I knew
I had one forming on my left but we
decided to wait until it was necessary
so when I went back in April of 2018 he
said yes it's time to get your lens done
in your left eye but in the meantime
you've lost some clarity in your right
eye so let's do a yag quick painless I
can do it right here in the office I
said you know I someone said that the
tribe CH to nation is doing that through
IHS and because I had so much outof
pocket expenses with the first
cataract let me check with them and if
they're doing it I would save myself a
ton of money and I said if they can't we
we'll make arrangements so I called the
clinic and they're like yes we can do
cataract surgery have a surgeon coming
in from Ada
but we can do the yag in office our
optometrist can do it so they made an
appointment same day appointment for the
surgeon and the optometrist the surgeon
to measure for the lens and the
optometrist to do the yag couldn't do
the lens because the optometrist had
forgotten to tell me to take my contact
lens out so I had to there was like an
additional seven days before he could do
that and he said but she can go ahead
and do your
y so I had been told quick and painless
that's the third person quick and
painless I was so comfortable sitting
there in that chair while she sat up I
remember her polish was gray I commented
on it and she said oh there Lee press on
nails from
Walmart and then she starts making
noises like
hm and then she said this is not working
right and my internal dialogue I'm a
pretty smart cookie my internal dialogue
started with well why doesn't she stop
and then it was completely overridden
with well she's a doctor if it it's not
working she'll know how to stop that
went on and then we stopped she put a
patch over it and she said okay you can
wear it till tonight and you can um take
it off tomorrow May the 9th 2019 my that
was my grandson's birthday he turned
nine that day I could still see to drive
with my left eye I lived an hour from
where I was drove home we had birthday
had patch on my ey I took it off later
that night and you know the Disney
mirrors the old oval Disney mirrors with
scratches out that's what it looked like
and I thought well by morning it'll be
it'll be
better I got up and it was not better so
I called the clinic and I'm like I can't
see is this normal does it take time to
heal and they said no you need to come
on in so I drive an hour back to Durant
and I saw a different optometrist and
they did an OTC
scan and she's like oh so she called um
Dean McGee a surgeon from Dean McGee I
institute sent him the scans she thought
it was an active
bleed he told her it was not an active
bleed and he would see me in seven
days that's all I knew so go home and
I'm think it's going to get better it's
going to get better it's going to get
better so I he comes to Durant I travel
back to see him weeks roll on
before he says this is permanent this is
not going to get any better she has
burned through your central vision what
you're seeing is all you're going to
see so he gives me his cell phone
number I don't know whose feelings were
hurt more that day his or mine he gives
me his cell phone number and he says if
you have a problem you you call
me go in about two weeks later I think
to get the will in September to get the
Cataract done in the
left
February I had a rental Detachment I
called Dr Franson I was at a basketball
game I called Dr Franson he said get to
OU ER so I went there couldn't do
surgery until Monday surgery was done
the 17th of February for the rental
Detachment cleared I could see again and
by November Scar Tissue had formed over
my eye still can't see out of this one
because it's permanent right Scar Tissue
had formed over my eye so we had to do
another surgery to remove the scar
tissue which set off an inflammation
storm so we started with steroids
prazone prelone did that for a year
could not get rid of the inflammation so
a uist got
involved and then a glaucoma special
got
involved I am considered legally blind
you can look at me and see I now have
tosis because this eye droops I've had
two surgeries to try to reduce the
glaucoma effects this eyelid droops due
to toes this eyebrow raises it's
permanent from trying to keep my eyelid
up to
see this eye other than
being not being able to see completely
healthy I don't have to see any
body this was my dominant eye this is
the eye I saw distance with I wore a
contact in this eye to read before this
storm I see colors I see
patches um this eye is on a good day I
can read my phone on a bad day I can't
do
anything she was talking about a patient
earlier who couldn't read her phone who
was 78 I went from managing
multi-million dollar compacts for the
tribe and
state to drawing disability I'm a
62 I played softball I played baseball
with my
grandson this is tragic but it's a
byproduct of surgery we all know there
are risk involved with surgery right I
signed the paper I was aware of every
step this quick and easy just a laser
get you in get you out restore all of
your Clarity this is
gone I have no central vision so I
listen
to what's right and what's wrong and
who's right and who's wrong I filed suit
after I worked for the tribe I prayed
about it talked to my director about it
didn't want to lose my job over
it till it got to the point point where
my director my executive director is
like you file chart you file suit
contacted a personal injury
attorney the optometrist that did this
was under contract for
IHS so it went through federal court we
mediated she paid me over $600,000 and
she had to admit negligence I don't know
where it was reported I don't know if it
was reported I know she's still doing
them today in Oklahoma she's still doing
them for IHS so I don't know what the
reporting system
is if one
person is
helped by learning all of the
information it's not quick it's not easy
it's there are it is not a it's a zero
risk it's a that's not
true just like that I went from she's
wearing gray fingerna polish to I can't
can't
see I don't have anything else to add
except for I hope that when you when you
make your decision and you vote you vote
knowing there are risk and there are
people behind
this do you have any
questions I don't see any thank you for
sharing your story and I'm so sorry for
what happened to you thank you I
appreciate your time
Joseph
shutler greetings uh I am uh from
Oklahoma but I don't consider myself an
Oklahoma the reason for that is my
private practice was in Nebraska and
South Dakota where I practiced for about
about uh 25 27 years before I took a
position with North Eastern State uh
College of Optometry in Oklahoma in
talaa where I have been the last uh
seven or eight years I teach didactic
education to our students I teach our
students in clinical education I also am
involved in specialty care which is
where we do lid procedures minor lid
procedures we do uh some of the laser
procedures that have talked about I'm
also actively involved in providing
postsecondary or continuing education in
a variety of topics including these
procedures throughout the United States
and and in parts of Canada now I did
delineate a lot of what I was to say
because one of the instructions was
don't duplicate and a lot of that has
been well covered so I'm going to to
proceed along but my practices
previously in Nebraska and South Dakota
were located in States at that time that
could not provide these procedures that
we are talking about so I was into the
fourth cycle of my uh fourth quarter of
my career before I begin to do these
procedures now not only do I do them but
I have the opportunity to teach students
and I also have the opportunity to teach
people in my similar situation who have
been practicing for uh for many years as
some of these legislations continue to
happen I am very honored to say even
though I no longer have a South Dakota
license simply because I changed the
state where I needed it I am honored to
say that South Dakota became the 12th
state to provide some of these laser
experiences and better our patients
within the last few months and so I'm
excited for my partners or ex Partners I
guess who still practiced there so in
every state where we began to think
about can Doctors of Optometry provide
these
procedures a primary concern which has
been emphasized over and over on on both
sides today is we all want to take good
care of our patients we want to provide
competent health care and for more than
30 years NSU which is nor Eastern State
University Oklahoma College of Optometry
has been providing secondary education
including continuing education across
the country to Doctors of Optometry not
only to become competent but safe and
effective in performing these
procedures our opponents have taken and
termed this continuing education the
32-hour
course their claim is it's not possible
to learn these procedures in 32
hours on a weekend
course I wholeheartedly agree with them
it's not it wouldn't be POS possible for
me to learn how to drive an 18-wheeler
in 32 hours I can't hardly back up my
boat to get it into the dock in
Oklahoma and so what you have to
remember is this course whichever course
your board determines is most
appropriate this course is not taken in
isolation it is a multi-day rigorous
course with Hands-On training but what
it's doing is building on the four years
of Bachelor degree and four years of
doctorate degree that these candidates
come in with and also as in my case and
many of the doctors that have spoken to
you already years of clinical experience
years of clinical experience managing
these cases
preoperatively and post-operatively even
though the legislation board whatever
regulation of that particular state
would not allow me to do those
procedures when I began to manage
cataract surgery post-operatively and
pre-operatively with an excellent
cataract surgeon 40 years ago which is
about how long I've been practicing it
was an entirely different
procedure the eye was laid open from one
side to the other the risk were
astronomical astronomical is an
inappropriate word but the risk were
high much higher than they are today the
patients were hospitalized routinely for
post operative
care cataract surgery today in the hands
of a skilled
surgeon a very short period of time to
do the
procedure low risk of
complication today we can use a lens
that will give you good distance and
good near Vision sometimes without the
use of glasses some of you reme can
maybe remember those huge thick glasses
we had to use after cataract surgery
decades ago that's no longer done how
did our colleagues learn to do that if
they had been out 20 to 30 years they
didn't go back and redo their
residency they didn't take another
semester of medical
education they took the skill set that
they already
possessed and moved that forward well
that's what we're proposing to do here
is
optometrist not learn a brand new set of
skills in 32 hours but to take a skill
set that's already possessed an anatomy
that's already welln and just mature
that into the procedures that s Senate
Bill 440 is requesting we're simply
expanding the skill sets previously
acquired from didactic education during
Optometric training and years of
experience MDS do not have a Monopoly on
professional integrity and good clinical
judgment in every state where
optometrists are permitted by doctors
where optometrists are permitted by
legislation or board regulations to do
many of these similar
procedures there are optometrists still
remaining who opt not to do them they
recognize that's they're not not their
career path they may specialize in
fitting specialty contact lenses they
may specialize in visual therapy a
variety of things but there certainly
are many that would move forward in
doing these
procedures Doctors of Optometry will
apply their professional integrity and
good clinical judgment when performing
these procedures there are procedures in
Oklahoma that I am authorized to do
according to my
lure but there are times when I make the
decision that I need to make a referral
for this case or I need to bring in one
of my Optometric colleagues to do this
procedure and so we have to remember
that just when legislation and board
regulations moves forward it doesn't set
aside professional judgment it doesn't
set aside professional integrity and
clinical
judgment and I won't belabor this point
because it's been said many many times
but I am old enough and have practiced
long enough to can remember when we were
told in state house after state house
that optometrist should not use dilating
agents we should not look at the retinas
we should not have the dilating agents
necessary to test for
glaucoma that's legal now in all 50
states it's also an important part of
what we now simply consider Primary Care
Optometry and as was mentioned when oral
medications the use of glaucoma a agents
our ability to remove a corneal foreign
body this is part of primary care
optometry in all 50 states and not one
of them has there been such an outcry
that there's been a repeal or a change
as those bills move
forward time has proven that what
optometrists came to their state houses
to say over decades has been
correct bills similar to SB 440 granting
Doctors of Optometry the authority to
perform these additional procedures has
been passed in numerous States and by
numerous I mean 12 at this stage and as
you were uh others maybe involve simply
injections but it's quickly becoming the
norm It's Quickly becoming Primary Care
Optometry so I would just encourage you
to Grant my fellow colleagues who
practice here in New Hampshire the
ability to care for their patients in a
competent safe effective And Timely
fashion I certainly appreciate your time
I have been PR practicing conquered I
hope I said that right because when I
started out they corrected me several
times as to my pronunciation it is a
pleasure to see you you have a beautiful
community and if I can can answer any
questions I would be happy to do so
thank you so much for your testimony
perhaps we should have taken the
conquered pronunciation Bill a little
bit more seriously um then we did
representative Gro you have a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Dr settler
can you please tell me how long has
laser has a laser um been used in
surgery on the eye in by optometrist it
was allowed in 1988 and by
optomologist uh I I don't I don't know
the 1976 thank you 1976 and 1988 was
when Oklahoma was authorized as
optometrist to perform the procedure yes
and it's still not authorized here is
that what you're saying that is correct
okay thank
you any further
questions sing on thank you very much
for your
testimony uh Timothy
Blake oh I'm so sorry we did have a
question I totally missed it
representative thank you Mr chair and uh
thank you for taking my question I'd
like to raise again a question I alluded
to ear earlier as I'm looking at
information about ocular surgery
Fellowship which uh appears to prepare
um optometrist to perform uh certain
procedures and for example do at least
50 uh SLT procedures at least 50 yags um
at least seven cians right so like is
there a sense of
what um what is a
uh a minimum adequate number of
procedures that uh
uh people should have done to be able to
prove competency because well we're all
very familiar with C1 do and teach when
there's a big difference between
learning to put in an IV and doing
surgery on the eye so um my question is
about competency and numbers my I can
only speak to uh Oklahoma where I
practice with regards to uh our system
uh our students that uh have a desire
again there are some that uh may be
going to a state where they don't want
to perform this procedure or they are uh
specializing in contact lenses or a
variety of things but those have who
have an interest we like to use the term
enough I hesitate to give you an exact
number because one could then hold that
one accountable to that and maybe most
of them would probably be well over that
number residencies are also an important
aspect that we have in Oklahoma uh we
currently have four to five ocular
disease residencies those are
postgraduate optometrists who are those
are op those who have graduated from
optometry school been accepted into our
program in ocular disease residency that
gives them simply the opportunity again
to take the foundational knowledge that
they have gained in their Optometry
schools and the dactic and the uh uh
Labs that they have had gives them the
opportunity then to enhance that with
regards to seeing and doing more
surgical procedures
followup so I want to use as an example
obstetrics in Family Medicine Residency
programs there's a generally accepted
number or used to be 40 I don't know if
it's still 40 or 60 um uh vaginal birth
is pretty low risk and complication
compared to eye surgery and people can
tell you what that number is and so um
it's not just that you will or won't be
graduated it's also that a hospital
won't accredit you to provide that
procedure in their you know in their
facility so is there any kind of number
or standard or anything because nobody
has been able to provide a number for uh
what might be reasonable for
competency I think that varies again
from state to state uh with regards to
how the regulatory board that you are
anticipating uh with this bill setting
forth because there is there is variance
in situations there certainly are if you
desire to do so there are certainly some
board regulations Optometry board
regulations where you can identify a
number that they would have to have in
order to move forward and their board
sets that being from a state being from
Oklahoma I it's not professional for me
to suggest to other states what where
their board should set that level in
Oklahoma when I acquired my lure
remember I came from a state where I had
practiced for many years but did not
have access to this uh to to being able
to provide these procedures so what the
state of Oklahoma required was that I as
with anybody else coming from another
state with no access to ability to do
these procedures as far as formally for
their lure they required me to attend
dactic course they required me to do
laboratory work they then tested me both
written and uh tested me um in a lab
situation as well before I was granted
lenser so in Oklahoma that would be the
requirement having to my knowledge not
changed since it was originally set up
in
okay now that you got me going I have
another question I mean when we practice
in a hospital we have clear guidelines
in terms of what we can and we can't do
you're talking about out patient
procedures what's the oversight what are
the guidelines who establishes
those the guidelines would be
established by the board of Optometry in
the states that I'm familiar with which
include I have had licenses in Oklahoma
Nebraska South Dakota and Alaska and so
the board of of Optometry within the
legislative limit just like in Oklahoma
there are certainly some aspects that
are excluded from our law that we are
not permitted to do and that the board
of examiners could not grant us the
right to do without returning to a
legislative body to change
that I think you answered my
question if not I will leave you a card
and I'd be happy to address it in all
right Timothy Blake
good afternoon I'm Timothy Blake I'm an
opthalmologist for 18 years at nashwa ey
Associates I appreciate the committee's
attention
today Nash I Associates is a
collaborative effort of seven
opthalmologists and seven
optometrists uh I have been tasks with
speaking about access I think a lot of
the access points have been belabored uh
so far in the testimony today uh and I
was just going to follow up on a couple
of the points made uh by the last couple
speakers to start
with um we were the question was how
many patients to
achieve uh clinical proficiency to do a
procedure a surgery like an SLT glaucoma
or uh a yag
capsulotomy well it it is a little bit
of a moot question because the uh
optometrist in 22 of 24 schools can do
zero they cannot do surgery on live
patients so the uh the um the model the
synthetic suturing and the the model I
is what 95% of optometrists receive in
optometry school we've heard this
afternoon from representatives from
Kentucky and
from uh from Oklahoma and and these are
the states where the Optometry
schools uh have the scope to to allow uh
to teach on live
patients uh those are those are the
exceptions the other 22 Optometry
schools 95% of Optometry students uh do
not have an opportunity to train on live
patients before they enter practice
the gentleman from
Kentucky mentioned an accreditation body
uh perhaps in the future with
forthcoming guidelines on the these very
questions it seems to me that we're
putting the cart before the horse that
we should have the guidelines in place
what's necessary to achieve clinical
proficiency before we allow the
procedures
and then I I also just wanted to comment
quickly on the there on the concept of
of preventing competition uh
opthalmologist the house of medicine uh
controlling
markets uh and as I'm sure many of you
may know in as Physicians we're we are
compensated by insur insurance companies
we we have no control over
pricing we're paid according to the
Medicare allowable or commercials
commercial insurers that use the
Medicare allowable as a guid
line so we we can't set our prices uh we
cannot collude so to speak I think it's
hard to to call that a
monopoly as an extension of this idea
were we to introduce optometrists into
the surgical market so to
speak this would not introduce
competition to decrease prices the
allowable would be the allowable that
the cost would be the cost so that that
would not be a downward pressure on
prices I'll take just a a couple minutes
to maybe give a little different
perspective on the question of
access so laser machines and and
maintenance on laser machines is
expensive a yag laser costs in the range
of $60,000
maintenance on the order of $9,000 per
year do the optometrists who serve our
rural communities have the the number of
patients needed to support P purchasing
a
laser uh one model is to pull Capital
among Optometry offices and disparate
locations to purchase and maintain a
laser uh this is not an access
solution and then secondly does the
number of patients in a rural location
support the number needed to a treat uh
to treat and and Achieve adequate skill
and
proficiency there is a whole body of of
of studies uh body of knowledge uh on uh
that demonstrates that one of the most
important predictors of surgical
complications is low surgical volume
surgeons who do fewer surgeries than a
critical threshold have more
complications
that's all I have for you this this
afternoon any
questions and then
Murphy yes thank you so the Board of
Medicine does they do they require um op
opthalmologists to perform their
surgeries and training on life
patients does the Board of Medicine uh
yes uh
there are there are a few guidelines
that the Board of Medicine um and then
residencies have specific accrediting
bodies uh in the case of Opthalmology
that's the
acgme and we have required amounts of
each surgery in order to um to be
considered competent uh that is the
first level of uh of training to
competence and and doing those
um that uh given number of procedures
and then your your surgeon um the the uh
the staff has to also sign out that
you're not only competent but that
you're ready to uh treat patients in the
real world I have followup followup and
what what did what has what how how has
the Laser Technology improved since it
was first initiated since it was first
started
not sure I could speak to that there's a
lot of different lasers for a lot of
different applications I think that
there's been uh certainly improvements
over the
decades thank representative
Murphy thank you madam chairman thank
you for taking my
question um first question my question
is um you have an office that has both
optometrist and Opthomologist is that
correct correct how do the optometrist
feel about this bill going going
forward we haven't talked about it
much thank you followup followup yeah I
you know I I I think it's it's a good
question in so far as in our office we
have comprehensive opthalmologists we
have glaucoma trained
opthalmologists so there are um when I
see a patient that has progressing
glaucoma in our practice I'm I'm having
that patient one of the glaucoma trained
opthalmologists so uh
there it would be hard to make an
argument in our practice there's a
demand for uh Optometry to be doing
glaucoma
lasers followup follow thank you in in
North Pedic my practice you know you
would have to have at least 25 or 50
joints per year in order to qualify for
continuing to do those procedures for
the reasons that you mentioned that
there are increase risks with the few of
the procedures that you do basically but
my question really is one of the access
versus the quality uh part of what we're
talking about today I don't want to get
into The Optimist versus the optometrist
my focus has always been what is the
best thing for the
patient and from what I'm hearing from
you can you speak to the the the
question in my mind is for the patients
from the patients perspective the
quality of care versus the access of
care which one did they prefer and where
do you see the difference being between
the
two yeah it it's an important Point
obviously we are uh as has been said
many times here today our number one
priority is patient care and and patient
safety and uh access is not important if
if we don't have quality of care
I I think the point becomes even a
little more important when you consider
that in these states where uh Optometry
scope has been expanded these are a lot
of the big Square States out west and
Midwest uh Alaska um Wyoming Alaska the
two uh lowest densely populated uh
states in the country um New Hampshire
being a small state is actually in the
upper half of uh population density so
um a as a from a population density
standpoint uh New Hampshire is in pretty
good shape uh as far as access to an
opthalmologist thank
you Mani thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question and I know NASA I
Associates very well I part of one of
the patients there
um are all opthalmologists
right uh eye surgeons are
all um eye surgeons I know all ey
surgeons have to be opthalmologist but
are all
opthalmologists I
surgeons uh there are opthalmologists
that are are medical opthalmologists
that are not eye
surgeons um some subs Specialties such
as neuro
Opthalmology uh does not do surgery and
um in some cases Retina
Specialists uh don't do uh more involved
retina surgeries thank one followup
thank you madam chair so the scope of
practice for opthalmologist is defined
by a specialty similarly would that be
something that optometrist are also
saying not all optometrists are going to
be practicing laser or doing surgery
is that a true
statement well it's true it it to the
extent in the in a world where
optometrists were were being trained to
do these
procedures thank you represent
Schmid thank you madam
chairman so
uh I my question is whether you think
that the status quo is immutable that
we're not going to see any uh expansion
of
optomet ability to practice so is that
your view that that's the case or do you
see that it is inevitable that the
optometrist are going to get uh some
additional procedures in any case uh and
that uh that we have to get it right if
we're going to be one of the states
that's going to move forward in this
direction what do I want or what do I
think is going to happen um I think I
can impute a certain desire on your part
but I won't do that I want you to
answer well um I I do think it's
important that anybody doing surgery
have the uh have have the training to do
it and so um I I think we can um
agree on some procedures that are are
beyond the current scope of the
optometrist but um without the the
appropriate training it's hard to uh
it's hard to agree to procedures or to
support them doing procedures that um
cut penetrate alter tissues inside the
eye
followup follow up so we're going to
have to uh you know there's going to be
a subcommittee and we're going to have
to have people participating who have a
very strong background but also uh
different positions on the spectrum of
acceptance whatever I believe you said
you're from Nashua uh and so it's
relatively nearby a lot closer than
Kentucky or
Oklahoma um so would you be possibly one
of those sub subcommittee participants
so that we can have your expertise help
us to get to it thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you David
cabin Madam chair may I respectfully
respectfully request that I with my
colleague Dr Who has to get out
certainly thank
you hi there uh thank you so much for
letting me go ahead head and speak and
my apologies if I watch the clock a
little I have to go pick up my son from
daycare in a little bit um we're running
into our time limit too we perfect so
I'm gonna go fast uh first of all just
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak with you my name is Dr Jessica Eid
I'm an optometrist and I practice in New
London New Hampshire and I basically
just wanted the chance to tell you a bit
about my background before I practiced
here in New Hampshire I'm not from here
I'm originally from Texas and Kentucky I
had attended optometry school at the
University of Houston during my time in
optometry school I spent years managing
complex medical eye conditions during
that time I treated patients in Texas
but also in Louisiana and Oklahoma so
even though I was in a state where I
wasn't able to do lasers in Texas I
still got many many live Human
experiences of these
procedures in other states where I could
do it so
as a student in a state without those
same allowances it still can be done and
is done that's how I got those live um
experiences as a student was going to
other states so after that I then
completed a residency uh in Tulsa
Oklahoma following my residency I then
began practicing in Kentucky because
that was a state where I could continue
to practice to the full extent of my
education now my husband husband and I
moved here to New Hampshire for his job
as a general surgery resident but if it
were not for his job here New Hampshire
would never have been on my radar as it
is not a state where I can practice to
the full extent of my training while I
have grown to love New Hampshire with
all of my heart and I hope to live here
for good staying here is not the best
decision for for my career as I am
Limited in how I can care for my
patients I cannot tell you how many
times I have seen a patient that needed
one of these procedures in order to
preserve their vision and I've had to
tell them I have done this procedure on
live humans countless times I could do
it for you here today however the state
of New Hampshire will not allow it so
instead of being able to help them I
have to refer them to an opthalmologist
which in the best of cases results in
delay of care which can threaten Vision
in the worst of cases a patient does not
have the transportation means to get to
an opthalmologist especially in the in
the rural given the rural nature of our
state and where I practice so to hear
anyone that practices in this state say
that there is not an issue with access
to care is just stunning to me because I
see it every day in my practice please
listen to me when I say there is a major
issue with access to care for my
patients and so this is becoming more
and more of a problem as opthalmologists
in our region are so busy that many will
not accept new patients as we've
discussed already causing us to have to
refer them even further away the problem
is only getting worse a solution is so
obvious which is to allow us to practice
the way that we were trained in my case
allow me to practice in New Hampshire
the same way that I have practiced in
Louisiana Oklahoma and Kentucky if New
Hampshire wants to attract the best to
the state and to take the best care of
their residents it is imperative that we
are allowed to treat our patients to the
full extent of our education thank you
so
much thank
you okay okay Laura
gonzala hello afternoon Madam chair
members of the board thank you so much
for having me here and your patients
with all of our testimony this afternoon
um my name is Dr Laura gazala I'm a
fellowship trained oculoplastic surgeon
brand new Dartmouth and I'm happy to wax
rodic on my training from aerospace
engineering to medicine but in the
interest of time I will uh suffice to
say that I did indeed graduate from the
26th grade it's my dad's favorite joke
and I am here mostly to talk about
access at Dartmouth uh I am one of four
new opthalmologists starting this year
at Dartmouth one of them will also be
practicing at Mount Ascutney she'll be
splitting her time two of us have
already started and as to the concerns
about aging opthalmologists I am the
oldest of the four new opthalmologists
so we have some time um We additionally
have started the first Opthalmic
residency in the state of New Hampshire
and we will be graduating our first
class this year so we have eight
opthalmologists in training at Dartmouth
uh seeing patients at the hospital
through the Good Neighbor Clinic in
Lebanon and they also rotate at the VA
and I will also be joining the VA uh
later this year and uh as to that point
I did want to clarify that the VHA I en
Vision Care directive 1121 does not
allow for optometrists to perform laser
or incisional surgeries at any VA
facility even in States like Oklahoma
where by state law optometrists are
allowed to perform those procedures
they're not allowed to perform them at
VA facilities that's just Federal
policy as for myself I'm an oculoplastic
specialist and I can and have been
seeing patients referred for iions
within a week and I talked with Dr
michaelc yesterday she's our newest
retina surgeon and she confirmed that if
someone is referred for an urgent
retinal concern she will see them within
24 hours and Dr schy one of our
residents that here is today somewhat
wearily confirmed that because he was on
call at the time uh in summary Dartmouth
is growing we're dedicated to safe
timely and effective patient care I do
want to have one gentle rejoiner that
50,000 cases with no reported
complications is perhaps not something
to celebrate given our colleagues notes
that everybody has
complications and not reporting them
potentially suggests a fairly Cavalier
attitude towards patient safety thank
you so much for your
time thank
you yes
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um for an elective
procedure of many sorts of any sort
whether it's a total joint or whatever
it could be you know two months before
you can get in to see somebody I
understand that and that's an issue that
is a potential access issue but my
question specifically to you is that at
Dartmouth have you ever or do you know
of anytime an acute emergency or urgent
patient was needed to be seen that could
not be seen at Dartmouth no I do not
thank you
thank
you thank you madam chairman thanks for
taking my it's a would you believe
question because this access issue keeps
coming over and over again but would you
believe that access is hardly just a
problem in this state for Opthalmology
and would you believe that patients will
drive from the North Country two hours
to see a provider for virtually any type
of care in the state and would you
believe is that your experience I would
absolutely believe that I'm coming here
from Portland Oregon which is one city
in a very large Square State that's
responsible for approximately 75% of the
population of that state so I routinely
had patients drive six hours to see me I
did my fellowship in West Virginia
another rural care with a rural state
with access issues and again I had
patients coming from as far a field as
Kentucky Ohio Western Virginia uh it's
it's medicine in general I
agree thank you
thank you again all right David
Cavin eight shows there we go thank you
again for allowing me to address the
committee uh my name is Dr David cin as
I said I you can probably tell by my
white hair that I've been here a long
time I started practicing in
1977 October and I recently retired in
mid
2021 um I want to say that this is at
least the third time that I have been
here in conquered to testify about a
bill in support of an Optometric statute
I will also say that three of the
speakers who have spoken were in the
same room with me opposing those bills
but in spite of them you did in fact
pass them all of them over time and the
outcomes have been I think
exemplary quick introduction and then
I'll get to the point because I know
it's running late during the final years
of my Optometric career I thought it
would be good to give back to the
community I sold my practice and moved
on so I had the honor and privilege to
serve as the associate medical director
of eye care services for the Amis geg
Health Center in Manchester New
Hampshire this is a federally qualified
Health Center it serves the most needy
the most underserved population in the
state and I want to address access
because frankly I am quite upset about
the testimony that we don't have access
issues we do have severe access issues
so I'm going to go up I'm going to stop
talking about myself and I've been asked
by the current director Dr Jillian PB
PID who is now the director of the mseg
ey Clinic who couldn't be here today
because she's in a dentist office who's
not an MD by the way but who's cutting
her mouth open to take out wisdom teeth
and so forth she's asked me to make a
presentation and I will quickly do it
and I'm going to cut out some of it but
you have her written
testimony she basically says that her
father was a physician her mother
retired nurse and that's why she decided
to come back to New Hampshire to
practice
Optometry she asked for your support in
Senate Bill 4 440 she says I have
experienced in Manchester a Time town a
city of 100,000 people roughly I believe
I have experienced significant
difficulty in finding the Specialty Care
my patients desperately need our current
Optometry statute as you know and I
won't belor it prohibits what's in
Senate Bill 440 so let me get right to
her story she has two of
them for example she says just last week
now I got this a week ago so it was two
weeks ago I had an uninsured patient
with a month's old lump in his eyelid
causing him
discomfort he was um a simple injection
into the lesion which would be allowed
by Senate Bill 440 that she had been
trained I'm going to say speaking this
in the first person that I had been
trained to do could have been completed
the same day for this patient and it
might have resolved the condition
instead my patient had to refuse my
suggested referral to a local
opthalmologist because the Opthalmology
consult and injection was cost
prohibitive these are people with no
money or little money as one of my
patients has put it to me I can barely
afford a loaf of bread let alone an
outof pocket referral to an
opthalmologist case number two and I'll
be ending this okay I'll give you an
example of a patient I regularly see and
could treat safely treat with a
procedure that I was per trained to per
perform in optometry school but cannot
perform due to the current Statute in
New Hampshire I'll call the patient Sam
Sam first saw me when I was a fourth
year Optometry student intern at the um
Community Health Center the manchest
said she was my student intern when I
was medical director Sam came in
covering her left eye in tears this is
the patient her husband had recently
passed away and over the previous week
she had developed a debilitating
Headache nausea blurred vision in her
left eye and severe eye
pain our colleagues in Opthalmology have
spoken about this and all the
misdiagnoses that we've made but here's
the story this patient had been
misdiagnosed by the ER who told her that
she was having migraines brought on by
her husband's death she went then to her
primary care physician an MD who told
her oh you've got an eye infection and
he prescribed Tylenol and an
antibiotic and guess what she ended up
in Dr pid's Clinic a day or two later
who and Dr peid Who I'm testifying for
immediately diagnosed her condition as
acute angle closure glaucoma angle
glosser glaucoma is a potentially
blinding condition where the anatomical
area in the front of the eye that
normally drains fluid gets
blocked and this can cause rapid rapid
Rises and pressures and it is truly an
ocular
emergency I immediately administered
topical and oral medications that we had
in the eye clinic and which I am
authorized to prescribe by former
legislation that we were opposed on 20
plus years ago by the opthalmologist
three of whom have already testified
against this bill okay so she used those
medications to just
delay just delay the
problem um I lost my place sorry so
basically the definitive treatment Dr PB
speaking the definitive treatment for
this condition is an in office laser
procedure that I was trained Dr peid to
perform an optometry school you might
think the story ends
there that I performed the laser
procedure and we saved Sam's
Vision that is not the case our current
law again prohibits this
so Dr peid states only opthalmologist
can perform the procedure but Sam a
single working mother did not have
insurance to cover such a procedure at a
local opthalmologist office she couldn't
afford it instead Sam had to drive over
60 minutes I'm assuming and I don't know
perhaps to Dartmouth a away to receive a
laser treatment from an opthalmologist
who re who agreed to do it at a reduced
price this procedure saved the vision in
the left eye of the patient but with
angled closure you need to treat the
other eye relatively quickly because
it's likely to occur in the other
eye faced with the and so it was
recommended to the patient but faced
with a $1,000 bill plus and and a over
60-minute
drive Sam told me Dr P that she had to
refuse the second procedure because she
couldn't afford the cost this is
happening in Manchester New Hampshire in
a clinic that serves
16,000 uninsured or underinsured people
so it's not an issue of access just in
those counties that Dr uh Sawyer
mentioned it's
everywhere and to final to make it final
I've have been trained to perform this
laser procedure if Senate Bill 440
passes our health center could procure
funding through a grant of a private
Foundation as medical director of iare I
can tell you that is exactly true we
have many foundations Cogswell and
others that would immediately pay for a
laser and we could have offered it to
not only this patient but to our
patients
immediately I have countless stues of
other patients who require the same
services that I'm not trained that I'm
trained to do but prohibited from
doing and that's I chose to come back to
New Hampshire it would make sense if I
could do them and then she just goes on
to ask your support for Senate Bill 440
my experience is just one to many
reasons why I respectively ask that
Senate Bill 440 be passed into law thank
you for your time Dr Jillian P any
questions
please yes sir thank you madam chairman
I I just want to say in medical school I
absolutely hated eyes every one of you
guys walks on water both sides how hard
is it to diagnose on narrow angle
glaucoma how hard to diagnose yeah
because it's been kind of brought up
that yes um I would say that for a non-
ey doctor I'd say for an optometrist and
opthalmologist it should be a
immediately diagnosed it's not at all
difficult to diagnose I've diagnosed
some cases myself I'm sure my colleagues
diagnose them all the time we diagnose
them all the time for a non ey care
medical
doctor it could be a bit more difficult
but an ER physician should certainly
have picked it up and they did
not thank
you thank you very much for allowing me
to testify appreciate it thank
you Dane
slint good afternoon and thank you for
having me here today my name is danne
slint I'm a board certified
opthalmologist and and fellowship
trained oculoplastic surgeon incate Bill
440 is dangerous to patient safety and I
will get into that with an example in a
second of how the exclusionary language
will actually harm a patient but before
I do that um I just want to clarify a
couple things as well
a lot of was brought up earlier today
was regarding the list of procedures
that were performed and Madam chairman
you were you hit the nail on the head
when you talked about the exclusionary
language because when you look at the
eyelid section it doesn't say they can
fix an outward turned eyelid it doesn't
say they can fix an inward turned eyelid
it doesn't say they can fix a sty it
doesn't say they can fix a papala it
says what they can't do and that's why
that bill is dangerous and the initial
list that was generated was when a group
of opthalmologists and I all went over
those possible procedures that we do as
a collective specialty 250 something
procedures were something within our our
realm that can be done including
liposuction including including breaking
nose bones and such because that's in my
my
purview um and the CP codes that were
listed is what's published by the
American um Medical Association and
that's where that information was um was
from the list that you see in the blue
book what was uh which came about from
negotiations that came from both sides
which I was not a part of but I was uh
part of making what is in that blue book
and the procedure that you see in that
blue book still still doesn't make sense
in terms of what's in the language for
example four of those CPT codes listed
are actually in response to a biopsy but
from the language in cabel 440
optometrists don't want to uh operate on
a lesion that they think is cancerous
but you do a biopsy if you're suspicious
of
cancer um we talked about earlier about
the number of Optometry schools that
were um um in state that can do lasers
only two of I believe the 23 states are
in those States so one of the questions
that we have though is you know how can
the majority of the um students get that
laser training that they need if only
two of those states are located in those
schools are located in those States but
more concerning it's more the
complications how are you going to see
those complications that arise and be
able to manage them when you don't see
them during that
training um and then we've heard
testimony from Miss rled today that her
complication has occurred in one of
these states
however it's not reported to the board
um on page 59 and 57 of the white book
uh you'll see language uh that both says
that they're not required to report
these complications to the board and
that's why often there there's oversight
there so getting back to my original
testimony um the first thing I want to
discuss since ocul plastic is in my
realm I'll be talking a lot about the
eyelids the eye socket in the tear duct
system today so diagnosing skin lesions
is difficult and requires substantial
medical training
Senate Bill 440 would allow non-med
doctors to judge if a lesan is cancerous
or not without ever seeing a physician
and if they don't think it's cancerous
they could operate on it and I'll pass
these around here in a little bit too um
but what you can see here and really
what I want you to pay attention to is
how similar the top and the bottom look
the top is benign the bottom is a Cancer
and they both look very
similar the top is a sty which has been
n in the bottom is cancer and I followed
up with this patient a couple weeks ago
and he's likely going to lose his eye
because of
this top picture is a sty it's benign
the bottom picture is an orbital tumor
they both look
similar in Tennessee an optometrist
actually operated on this top Legion up
here which he thought was a sty and when
it didn't resolve he finally sent the
patient to an opthalmologist the
opthalmologist diagnos it as a basil
cell cancer through a biopsy and what
you see on the bottom is the defect that
resulted from having to have that cancer
removed it was subst reconstructed by an
opthalmologist misdiagnosis of a
cancerous lesion can lead to blindness
or death and this is especially true
with melanoma similar cases can happen
in new New Hampshire as a result of
passage of this
bill this is sty surgery look how close
that needle and the scalp will come to
the eyeball the eyelid is only 2 mm
thick that's the same thickness as a
nickel it's of no surprise that
dermatologists and plastic surgeon refer
eyelid surgeries Optimist due to fear to
injuring the eye and sadly in Kentucky
an an optometrist stuck a needle into a
patient's eye during an eyelid surgery
this serious complication may lead to an
infection blindness or the need to
remove the S the eye um and their letter
um is documented in the back of your
white booklet as well approximately one
in 20 of the eyelid procedures that I
perform in clinic involve a patient
passing out and sometimes that looks
like a seizure opthalmologists undergo
extensive medical training including
rotations in the Eds and the icus to be
able to handle
emergencies speaking of emergencies the
eyelids have a rich blood supply this is
my patient on the left and she had
severe bruising after minor eyelid
surgery while she was okay what we fear
is this patient on the right the patient
I had on the right had bleeding behind
the eye in the eye socket the eye socket
is enclosed and this is called an
orbital compart compartment syndrome and
this requires urgent surgery within
minutes to prevent uh blindness that's
permanent to treat the compartment
syndrome you need to enter the orbit to
relieve that pressure opthalmologists
are all trained to perform the surgery
Senate Bill 440 specifically excludes
orbital surgery therefore passage of
this bill would Grant Optometry C
certain procedures but leave them unable
to manage a vision-threatening
complication that needs to be handled
urgently and as a result pass to this
bill would uh potentially cause New
Hampshire citizens to unnecessarily go
blind likewise we see a similar
situation with cosmetic injections
cosmetic fillers can cause stroke
blindness droopy Lids double vision and
skin death with the most common type of
filler treatment for filler Associated
blindness in includes injecting
medication into the orbit again if this
bill was pass optometer could perform
this procedure but be unable to manage a
vision-threatening
complication m diagnosis and the
inability to manage complications will
unnecessarily harm or blind a patient
please protect the citizens of New
Hampshire from the substandard medical
care that this legislation represents
and v no on Senate Bill 440 thank you
thank
you
repri okay so I get it this this bill
has got some problems is it
fixable because we're not going to vote
on this bill okay representative Schmidt
I think that's Beyond his scope okay you
that's your opinion my opinion is
different now the thing is
that we're going to have a subcommittee
and we're going to look at all these
issues that have been raised and I bet
you we're going to try and resolve the
issues so that we can do what's right
for New Hampshire we need help from
people like you who know what you're
talking about so you're willing to come
to the subcommittee and help us fix the
if it needs it count me in but I think
you you also said that right too you
know part of the the differences and we
heard from both um Kentucky and Oklahoma
today is that there's a vast difference
in the training in the states that
optometrics can perform surgery there's
no minimum there's no requirements need
be met whereas a medical school and
Opthalmology residency which is acgme
approved you have to meet certain
guidelines to be able to perform these
surgeries safely and that's why we are
all here
today thank you see you at the
subcommittee
representative
Murphy thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question um the
the language as you reference accurately
in the bill is exclusionary to what can
be done I don't know how many procedures
are done in Opthalmology um but where
would the where is the Delta between
what would be potentially done could be
done could be legislated to be done
versus what is excluded right now sorry
can you repeat that that first the
question is how many procedures would be
done could be done that are not listed
here you know I'm just trying to get a m
a sense fromet or from myself from the
optometrist in general or just opom I
believe you know the optometrist are
able to do somewhere around the 10 or 12
procedures that are listed in the back
of that blue
book right my my question though is the
Delta between what is potentially that
could be done I know how many versus how
many you know are excluded here and then
what are we left with how many we how
many surgeries have we left with so you
know I think the uh if I'm understanding
correctly and please correct me if I'm
wrong but you know the concessions we
made would include four other procedures
that they asked for I think would be
reasonable because it' be extensions of
what they're doing but not meeting the
definition of surgery um because we do
find out that it's harmless because we
feel that they're not adequately trained
for that um if if I'm answering your
question I I don't think so but um my
question I think we after we study the
blue the list of procedures in the blue
will have a better understanding of
what's included because the bill itself
does not specify exactly right that's my
question is what it what would be
allowable how many cases would be
allowable what are we talking hundred
yeah so from the initial um list that we
created that 250 something list was
based on the the exclusion criteria what
they could do as a result of that based
on how Opthomologist trained okay thank
you that answer your question yes it
does thank you
okay very good
Margaret
rice Madam chair and uh members of the
committee thank you very much for the
time today I'll try and keep it snappy
I'm here to provide a student
perspective uh for Optometry um my name
is Maggie Rice and I'm a resident of
keen and I'm a fourth year Optometry
student studying at the Massachusetts
College of Pharmacy and Health Sciences
in Worcester
next week I start my clinical rotation
and I'll be at the Northampton VA
providing comprehensive primary eye care
to Veterans which is very exciting after
completion of my doctoral program I hope
to return to the madok region to
practice during my four years of
rigorous postgraduate doctorate
education it is my privilege to be
trained in the most current health
research and be able to use
top-of-the-line technology and
techniques in my clinical um experience
we live in a time when medical
advancements are happening very quickly
every year we gain a better
understanding of the physiology of the
eye and body treatment options for
ocular disease are expanding and the
technology advancements allow for safer
more effective and more accessible
in-office
procedures my optimetric Education and
Training is preparing me to be able to
utilize the most current technology
and techniques and it's positioning me
to be able to uh use the most current
technology but also grow and advance in
the future and our New Hampshire
statutes should allow for our health
care providers to do just that the
passage of SB 440 is a Strategic
investment in the future of iare for our
state right now outdated regulations
prohibit New Hampshire patients from
receiving the full benefits of an
optometrist many years of training and
as a result of this optometrists who
want to practice their fullest
capabilities are encouraged to look
elsewhere and I think Dr Eid spoke to
this so I'll give you an example as well
I am the only student in my class of 50
in Worcester who is from New Hampshire
and I'm only one of a few who is even
considering New Hampshire as a place to
move to to practice and raise a family
so unless these regulations are
corrected New Hampshire will continue to
struggle to attract top Quality
Healthcare Workforce that it needs and
deserves the passage of s440 doesn't
only mean that New Hampshire residents
would have better access to care now and
in the future but also that students
like me would see the state as a place
where we can be the absolute best future
doctors for our patients and that would
really be a wonderful thing so I
encourage members of the committee to
vote Yes on s440 because it corrects
restrictive and outdated Healthcare laws
it will draw the best and brightest
Health Care Providers to the state and
it also expands access to uh high
quality health care for all of New
Hampshire right now but then also in the
future so I thank you again for your
time and considerations and I'm happy to
take questions thank
you I don't see s thank
you Katherine morando
thank you madam speaker thank you
representatives for your time I know
it's been a long day and I really
appreciate how seriously everyone is
taking this um my name is Katherine
mirando I'm an opthalmologist a
physician surgeon here in town at
conquered Eye Center I'm a glaucoma
specialist I'm here in strong opposition
to Senate Bill 440 out of concern for
the safety of my patients I have a
biomedical engineering degree in
addition to my medical degree and I did
my Opthalmology residency and fellowship
down at masser in Boston I wanted to
quickly touch on a couple things that
were mentioned to maybe clarify a bit um
there was mentioned that we're not going
to attract good optometrist to the state
because we're not offering the things
that they want to do that's simply not
the case based on the numbers if we look
at all the optometrist who left New
Hampshire none of them have filed CPT
codes or laser codes in States elsewhere
mean meaning they're not leaving because
they can't do laser surgery and the
numbers of optometrists are continually
growing in our state there's also a
question about providing care to
underinsured or lowincome patients we
actually have I'm not sure if everyone's
aware there are uh numerous programs
there's I Care America through the
American Academy of Opthalmology and my
Society with glaucoma we have uh
glaucoma Society cares where we
volunteer to provide free eye surgery to
underinsured and lowincome patients
there is also a comment earlier about um
that these surgeries are just a natural
progression from the didactic training
was the
wording um I think that's sort of
likening a pilot who maybe goes to
flight school and sits in a classroom
but has never flown a plane then saying
it's a natural progression from the
dactic level while never actually having
Hands-On training in a plane I would
like in
the change in the surgical field over
time and opthalmologists learning new
procedures to maybe switching from not
that I fly a helicopter to a plane you
know you're already operating on living
breathing humans in the same spaces and
just transitioning to more upgraded
procedures they also mentioned that
they're already doing uh procedures with
um sharp instruments here that includes
removing eyelashes and removing uh
debris from the surface of the eye and I
don't think um I just don't think that
is a translatable skill to what exactly
we're talking about here so I'll just
lead into my piece of this which is uh
the laser surgery being addressed in
this bill and what exactly we're talking
about this bill has a lot of confusing
language about what we don't want to do
but let's just get down to breast tax
and talk about what uh they are looking
to do there are three laser surgeries
the first is called selective laser
laser tcul plasty or SLT this is a laser
used to lower eye pressure electively in
glaucoma it's not an emergency usually
used for people who have Dementia or
difficulty with arthritis in
administering their drops in order to do
this laser the laser beam is aimed at
this structure that is half a millimeter
thick this probably looks like nothing
to you but there's a thin line here in
the middle it's very tiny if you aim
here or you aim here not only will it
not work but you can cause damage in
order to do this laser with one hand you
hold a lens on the eye that has a mirror
that flips and reverses your image with
your other hand you aim the laser at the
spot you're treating with your foot you
are pressing a button to apply the laser
and you do about 100 shots in between
every few pulses I'm adjusting the power
so that I don't cause damage or treat
too little it's a very active process
the second type of laser that they want
to perform is called um a yag iridotomy
or an
LPI this this laser creates a permanent
second hole in the iris like you can see
here can't be undone it's permanent it's
used to treat a certain type of glaucoma
very frequently you can get bleeding at
the time of this procedure because there
are blood vessels on the iris and you
have to actively treat that and modify
how you're doing your procedure and I
think being more recently out of
training I can hear and sometimes feel
my mentors guiding my hand as I'm doing
things and I think what exactly did they
do when we've seen this before to help
me through um those difficult cases the
last type of laser that they want to
perform is called a yag capsulotomy or
yag cat I'm sure some of you have had
cataract surgery in this room so
everyone's born with a lens in their eye
this uh diagram here they already had
cataract surgery I describe it to my
patients kind of like a grape that has a
grape skin and then the material inside
cataract surgery we scoop out the
material inside and leave a capsule so
here that capsule is holding the new
lens implant and about one in three
people it gets cloudy over time it's
elective it's usually slow yes it's
inconvenient but it's not Vision
threatening in a permanent way we get
you to the right treatment and it and it
improves so with this laser we direct
the laser inside the eye and create a
permanent hole in that capsule that
capsule is four microns thick that's one
20th the thickness of a piece of paper
very tiny if you're a few microns too
forward you crack the lens and that
patient may need a complicated lens
transplant too far back by a few microns
you hit the jelly here in the back of
the eye that jelly is touching your
retina and can cause retinal tears
retinal Burns retinal detachments and we
heard the unfortunate story already from
Miss
rutage I mentioned complications already
you have a longer packet from me with
good citations and more about these
complications so I don't want to belabor
the point I think from my experience the
most serious complication is incorrect
patient selection and I think some of my
colleagues have actually come to similar
conclusions and I say this because I've
already seen this numerous times
numerous furls for consider LPI consider
SLT consider yag cap when that only
would that have been the wrong procedure
to perform but it would have been
harmful to that patient to perform I
have a few examples I don't if if that
would be interesting to you or helpful I
can get into it otherwise um I will move
forward so I hope this gives you a
better understanding of the laser
surgery being discussed in this bill I
know the Optometry Lobby is going to try
to say how easy and safe these are to
perform but it's surgery a laser is a
tool used by a surgeon just like a
scalpel to cut manipulate or alter
tissues and the truth is that optometry
school has no Hands-On laser training
with patients required and in fact 22
schools can't even have Hands-On patient
training I really value my colleagues in
Optometry we are constantly working
together in the same office and I I
value their referrals because they're on
the front lines and and accurate
referrals is is what drives our practice
to get patients the right care so I hope
we can keep working to the highest
levels of our training but also
recognize our limitations so we're not
taking advantage of our less educated or
poor elderly citizens who don't know the
difference I mean this is a long hearing
to understand the difference they're not
going to know the level of
training so I'll I'll just end with a
question I guess for you that if you
needed to have laser surgery done on
your eye would you want it done by
someone who's done 177,000 hours of
Hands-On clinical training and has set
minimums or would you be okay with
having it done by someone who did a
weekend course on a Model eye because
someone has to be their first
patient thank
you thank you for your
testimony they had
fot f a z e l a
t excellent handwriting thank you a
doctor's
handwriting uh Madam chair distinguished
members of the committee thank you so
much for the time today it's been a long
day we've heard a lot of testimony so I
appreciate you bearing with
us you've heard a lot and hopefully by
now you're ging an understanding of the
differences between the opthalmologist
and the optometrist whether you liked it
or not you gained an education of it and
you know that there are differences
between the two you learned so much and
about the procedures how intricate they
are how detailed they are and you should
have heard exactly how much more there
is in the decision the medical decision-
making proc process than there is in the
actual treatment itself both of those
are so important to the whole process
we've talked significantly about access
and I know my colleagues um in Optometry
are very passionate about access as are
we and we all recognize that New
Hampshire is a state where the
population has put itself south of
conquered 80% north of conquered 20%
opthalmologists have put themselves in
the state south of conquer similarly as
have optometrists and so this problem of
access that exists we agree there is
this problem of access but not just for
our Specialties this is for medicine
Nationwide when we looked at the data to
actually review and see what was the
access issue for our patients we saw
that you could get to a trained
Opthalmic surgeon within 30 minutes 90%
of the patients surely Dr Sawyer has
patients that have more than an hour
travel and surely there others who could
give us similar examples but we're
talking about the rule not the
exceptions and that's why we're trying
to base good policy to answer the
problem right you wouldn't actually
introduce legislation that doesn't
answer the
issue we talked a little bit about the
safety uh of this procedure and when
it's done by Optometry and they hear Dr
alra sat and said we all have
complications but if you look at the
data that's posted they have zero zero
it strains crul it's unbelievable we
know looking at our own data many
thousands of cases the rates are about
133% complication we know that's why we
spend three years training residents
meticulously training residents watching
them in observation watching them
actually doing watching them teach their
younger residents watching them not only
as their chief resident as I did uh but
also as their fellow again many years of
just watching making sure that they're
ready for prime time this doesn't happen
with our Optometric colleagues the way
their curricula and education stands
today and I I have the utmost respect
and have partnered with so many on my
right to take care of all their patients
emergently and uh on an as needed basis
and I the my cell my cell phone number
is in most of these Pockets here and so
we partner with these guys all the time
to take care of patients and I don't
think that when they say when they make
statements like zero complications it
should raise antennas because we know
that's that can't be the case we have
Vicky rutage here from Oklahoma that
just tests the veracity of any comments
like that so it should give us all pause
and the way it stands now Dr coddle told
us here that some of his uh students
were very interested some of them were
not interested but yet they all graduate
so how am I to know the difference
between one who's very interested and
not interested one who's very well uh
you know capable at the procedure and
not if there are no minimums I don't
know the patients won't know and even
one Vicky rled is too many there is no
minimum number of complications that's
okay to you know to S to sanction this
kind of legislation for me that's why
we're all here because remember
opthalmologists and optometrists work
together in the same clinics the owners
of those practices of our
opthalmologists would benefit from this
legislation financially right more
operators doing surgery but yet here we
all are galvanized in opposition because
nothing would Trump patient safety
nothing there's no amount of money that
would trump
it the fiscal impact of this for us that
some have uh some have
said uh will be the reason we're
protecting our market share and that's
why we're our opposition of this bill
that's where it's a foundation is the
fiscal impact I've just shown you that
it would be little to none for us this
is particularly solely about safety for
us we don't want to see any Vicky rutage
like patients in our office we don't
want to deal with those complications
that will arise when you put operators
in their present level of training and
in their curricula when you put them out
into practice for all of us to Bear
witness to their learning curve we don't
want to do that we don't want to do that
in this state we
think we're pretty sure that's why the
last 13 states that where this
legislation has come up it has been
struck
down we are sure that by the majority
while they make it may make say this is
happening as Dr Cell told us to get on
board I won't get on board because
patient safety is too important for the
for me uh in this facet to just get on
board and go with it I don't believe it
is an inevitable wave that's coming I do
think we have to look at the data and
stay away from Hyperbole and anecdotes
and just trust the data that's why in
subcommittee I will be available to
answer those
questions thank you um I do have one
question do you know how many
opthalmologists there are in New
Hampshire anybody sure one of my
colleagues I thought it was 70 plus 70
plus thank
you I think I think more important
for me um is the damage um that this
legislation had done is once
complimentary pieces and will do if
passed once complimentary pieces in New
Hampshire to help take care of all the
vision problems that our Granite Staters
have now they are seen as
Alternatives uh competitors to each
other that relationship between the
optometrist and the Opthomologist is so
important and legislation like this is
fracturing it and patients will suffer
for
it I I don't want this kind of
legislation to pass specifically for
that reason I would be the if the
training was changed in the optimetric
community such that hours of of of laser
and surgical training were applied such
that minimums were guaranteed such that
watch door uh or organizations like the
AC gme would come to every Optometric
school and ensure that their graduates
were uh graduating with minimums and
there was a National Standard sign me up
let's do it but until that happens it
can't be okayed by legislation on the
back end this should be a national
Grassroots effort to change the way
Optometry is taught and practice at the
level of the curricula in the schools
not with legislation state by
state they continue to say what where
where if if this legislation causes
problems where are where are they we're
wondering the same it could be if I
would offer that when you're faced with
a patient who suffered a complication
either delayed diagnosis or
misdiagnosis or in in these states where
the procedures are allowed complications
from the procedure itself the doctor and
the patient are not engaged in
culpability that's my last concern uh
whether
uh it's specifically the patient in
front of me and the problem that they're
presenting with that I'm focused on and
culpability is the furthest thing from
my mind at that time until I can
guarantee the best outcome for my
patient now originally from
Afghanistan moved here from
Missouri I am a granted stator now
because I married a girl from Bedford
and here I will stay and it I will be in
opposition to bills and bills like this
that put patients in danger because it's
my duty not just for the time that I'm
in practice but it it's going to be my
legacy to the
state I have time for any
questions thank you very
much all right don't see any questions
at the
moment all right is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on Senate Bill
440 thank you
no they've already uh we've already
gotten a good supply of them in that
case I'm closing the public hearing it
will be going to subcommittee and it
needs to be voted out of this committee
by
miday e